[inaudible].
Yeah.
All right.
We're all,
here we go.
Jordan Peterson,
Ben Shapiro,
Dave Ruben.
We got a lot to do.
We've got about two hours to do it.
I thought,
how am I going to start this thing?
I could ask you guys how you're doing.
We could dive right into some deep topics,
but then I thought,
no,
let's do something else.
A lot of people don't seem to like us that that is a weird thing.
We've been bouncing around quite literally all over the world the last couple of
months and we're meeting thousands and thousands,
hundreds of thousands of people at this point.
Huh?
Who are decent good people from every walk of life trying to find some answers
and meet other people that think like them or don't think like them,
but just,
but just want to find some decency in this world.
And yet the online world just seems relentlessly hateful and you probably get
more hate than anyone else.
So I thought that would just be an interesting way to start this like just as
three people that I think we're basically trying to put some decency out there.
Just sort of the level of anger and hate that we get.
I'll,
I'll go to you first year.
Does it bother you anymore?
Oh yeah,
it did.
I mean I try to shield myself to it from it to some degree.
I mean I'm certainly decreased the amount of time that I'm spending reading
Twitter comments to pretty much zero.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
I find the,
uh,
the contentious interchanges with journalists I would say are the most stressful
things that I do.
And they usually rattled me up for a day or two afterwards.
Um,
even though I would say they're still worth doing.
but
the,
the here,
here's the thing.
Okay.
So a couple of observations.
The first is a lot of the pejorative comments that have been aimed at me,
for example,
have been that my followers are a bunch of angry young white men.
And so I'd like to take that apart a little bit.
The first thing I've learned in the last month or so thought through is that I'm
done making any sort of apologies whatsoever for the fact that most of the
people who are watching my youtube videos are,
are men.
There's nothing wrong with talking to men.
And if man happened to be benefiting from what I'm discussing,
then so much the better women have to live with men.
And so that's of great benefit to women.
And there are plenty of women writing me telling me that and also meeting me at
these talks saying exactly the same thing.
And then they're not angry.
So in how do I know that?
Well,
as you just pointed out,
we have spoken to 250,000 people in seven months.
How many incidents of anger have we had?
I mean,
what I tell you,
literally none.
Zero,
zero,
zero [inaudible] the shows have been loved that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're very,
very positive.
Yeah.
So,
and we had one heckler who was obviously not a fan in one venue.
I wasn't even at that show that it wasn't your fault.
Oh God,
you land.
Exactly.
So the the couldn't possibly be more peaceful or positive as far as I'm
concerned.
And so,
and then the people there aren't particularly young.
I would say the average ages is somewhere between 30 and 40 and there's plenty
of older people and especially in the u s now it's at least a third women for
what that's worth.
And I think that's because women are buying more of the books.
In Europe it was still more men,
but that's because in many of those countries,
the book had only come out recently.
Yeah.
And you have to,
it's definitely not the way the media portrays it.
They're making it seem like it's 90 10 I mean,
I always say at the beginning of the show when I reference something about that,
I usually say it's 60 40 and yet be,
sometimes it's a little more one way or the other,
but it's certainly not the way.
Well,
I think a lot of the vitriol is,
see I was,
I just finished reading another book on postmodernism and Oxford Book on
postmodernism and on Dera Dha in particular.
And like there really was an attempt on the part of the postmodernists and this
is allied,
I think with their fundamental Marxism to demolish the idea of the autonomous
individual.
So for example,
one of the things that's really interesting about the current free speech debate
is that it really isn't a debate because you have to be in the Judeo Christian
slash enlightenment tradition to believe in free speech.
Because to believe in free speech,
you have to believe that they're autonomous individuals who have their own
viewpoints,
who can spontaneously generate creative ideas and then who can engage in an
active dialogue in a,
in a,
in a manner that that is,
that consists of fundamental goodwill and truth and that you can change each
other's opinions and that you couldn't come to a negotiated agreement.
You have to believe all of that,
including the autonomous individual in that concept,
the logos,
which is what Derrida was.
So,
so,
uh,
what he criticized so heavily that idea of low logo centrism,
you have to believe in the autonomous individual and the postmodernist and the
Neo Marxists,
they don't,
they believe that the individual is a mouthpiece for a power assembly.
And if there is no such thing as free speech,
which is why they know platform,
right?
It's not,
well it is,
it's,
so the debate about free speech is way deeper than who should be allowed to
talk.
The debate about free speech is whether or not there is such a thing as free
speech outside the power game that neo colonial Europeans are playing.
And so what I'm doing and what you're doing with me,
and I think what everybody in the IDW is doing to some degree is speaking to
people as if they are autonomous individuals who are the bedrock of civilization
and sovereignty.
And that is absolute and neath Emma to the radical left.
And so they,
they,
they see that as a fundamental challenge,
which it is
the individual is the fundamental challenge.
I think that's perfect for you because it's like you as an individual,
Ben Shapiro,
you get more hate online than pretty much anyone.
And it's not just that you get hate,
it's the nature of the hate where that you're a white supremacist.
You happen to be wearing a Yamaka,
which is a little confusing.
You know that you are,
that you're a Nazi or the rest of it.
And it's like,
I know you're okay with criticism,
but it's not criticism that they're leveling.
It's just endless hate.
It's endless over the top eight.
And that,
that's the weird,
you know,
if you're
a good person,
you try to be a good person.
Every time you receive a piece of criticism as a good person,
your first response should be,
did I do something wrong?
Was it make right?
And yeah,
and as somebody who's trying to get better at being a human and also just at
what I do,
I spend an awful lot of time trying to look at those criticisms and say,
okay,
is that reasonable?
And usually it's something from 10 years ago it was like,
okay,
yeah,
I should have done that better.
That was those stupid,
I shouldn't have said that.
Right.
Yeah.
It isn't always 10 years ago for you because you even had that nice moment in
this studio where you had said that you have a sort of public and private
position on addressing trans people by pronouns that they want.
Right.
100% you don't want to be bludgeoned into doing it,
but privately if you knew someone who was trans and respected them,
of course you would use the pronouns.
Right and then in the same way that I would do that with,
with anybody about anything.
Generally,
if I'm been in private conversation with somebody and I don't,
when I want the conversation to progress beyond something that's unrelated,
then I'm not going to go out of my way to offend them because it's,
it's pointless.
But in a public conversation where the,
the express topic being discussed is human biology,
then I'm not going to give into the argument that I have now given up my
argument by using the Pronoun of your choice because that is undercutting my own
argument.
We're now in a public debate.
That's a different forum.
Um,
but that idea is that you are unsympathetic and I think this goes to the
fundamental conceit of folks on the left,
which is that they are more sympathetic human beings and people who opposed him
politically or unsympathetic human beings in this goes back to the individual
versus communitarian distinction for the left.
If you're an individual,
this means that you are inherently unsympathetic to others because your
individuality stands against the collective.
Yeah.
If you are,
you're,
you're a member of the collective,
then you can show that by your,
the amount of sympathy that you have to have her have her other people.
And so I think,
but also so for
the collective and for the whole,
for a very weird form of sympathy,
right?
Because the collective doesn't suffer,
individuals suffer.
Right.
You know,
and,
and that's,
uh,
and then the other thing that's interesting about that reflects of
identification of sympathy with virtue is that it's actually extraordinarily
immature as far as I'm concerned,
because most complex problems aren't,
uh,
aren't solvable by reflects of sympathy and reflects of sympathy is more like,
it's more like an instinct.
It's more like anger or it's more like jealousy or rage or love for that matter.
It doesn't have that cognitive component that enables you to take apart complex
systems and to analyze them and determine what the problem is and what a
solution might look like.
And then to lay that out in a cold and calculated manner toward some positive
end.
It's this automatic assumption that because you're overwhelmed with pity,
let's say that that somehow makes you morally virtuous.
And it not only does it not make you morally virtuous,
it's often the case that that,
and this is the big Friday observation,
that that all encompassing pity actually has a devouring component.
And that's that overprotectiveness that while the Jonathan Height and Lucan off
have been writing about,
for example,
and it's very,
it's,
it's that interferes with the development of people's autonomy.
And so the reflexive idea that because you're a sympathetic person,
you're good,
right?
Is,
is bad enough in addition to the fact that,
well,
all the sympathy is on the radical left,
which is certainly isn't,
I think one of the things that height talks about,
and this is where I think the left has taken advantage in so many areas.
And I'd say the left,
and I don't mean people who are liberal,
I always make this distinction.
There are people who are on the left,
are liberal,
appreciating it,
right?
And this is Dave's point all the time.
If you are for free speech,
but you disagree with me about tax rates,
you're liberal.
If you're somebody who's on the left and you want to shut down debate because
you fundamentally believe that free speech is a conceit of the power structure,
right then then you are on the left.
But what height says,
and he's correct about this,
is that in any conversation you have with anybody there sort of an entry gateway
to the conversation.
And that is showing that you have goodwill.
So showing sympathy is one form of doing that.
So what the left likes to do is prevent the conversation from happening by
preventing you from appearing as a sympathetic human being.
Meaning that,
so for example,
when I talk about transgenderism,
the first thing that gets thrown at me is you don't care about transgender
people.
Why are we even having this conversation?
You're trying to be mean.
You're trying to create violence against transgender folks.
And this is why this language is constantly used.
Because if we accept that I have tremendous empathy for people who are suffering
from what is by any measure a disorder.
And if I say that we have to look at sympathy for these people and try and find
the best scientific solutions and try and figure out what's best for society
generally,
not just for transgender folks,
but for kids who were teaching,
who can be easily confused about gender or if we're looking at what's the best
solution for doctors who,
there was an article in the New York Times,
like last week with a person suggesting the doctor should be forced to perform
transgender surgery simply based on one's not even based on an assessment of
need.
The doctor should not be able to assess whether somebody needs the transgender
surgery or whether alerts basically the situation in Ontario already in Canada.
Yeah,
I mean it's on demand.
It's just like any other optional surgery now.
I mean,
this sort of stuff has real societal consequences and to be,
and so what the left will do is they don't want to talk about the societal
consequences.
Instead what they do is they say,
you're not welcome in the conversation because you're unsympathetic.
And so this is usually what's thrown at me.
And you know fairly enough in the sense that my slogan is facts don't care about
your feelings,
but what I mean by that is not that you shouldn't care about other people.
It's that in the end the solutions that are going to lead to better lives are
not going to be feelings based.
They're going to be facts,
space.
This is not me.
I have to be an unsympathetic human being.
So for example,
is a story that I really haven't told publicly because I don't like to tell
these stories publicly because my monities has a basic principle of charity,
which is the best form of charities,
anonymous charity because then you don't get credit for it.
It's all right.
I don't want to make it seem like this happened simply because I was trying to
take credit for it,
but several weeks ago I was speaking at a university which will remain unnamed
for anonymous for anonymity reasons and I was,
and this topic came up,
a transgender person got up at the microphone and asked a question and the
conversation kind of went sideways.
The person suggested and started talking about their personal story and I
started kind of picking holes in the personal story a little bit and it's
probably an exchange that I could have handled better.
But in any case,
the person got very upset and started to cry and then left and this is all on
tape and it was one of those situations where,
because I give speeches in,
in Q and a forums and because there are a lot of videos of me destroying people,
it's one of those situations where if the tape comes out,
it gets 5 million views and it Shapiro destroys transgender,
right?
And I don't want that to be what happens at my lecturers.
If there's going to be a Shapiro destroys video,
which we don't even cut,
then I would like it to be like just a rational exchange where everybody leaves
feeling good about the exchange and somebody lost in somebody's one fine,
this was something different.
The person got visibly,
emotionally upset,
very upset I,
and the people who are running the event happened to know who this person was.
So I called the person up on the phone and I said,
that really didn't go how I want it to go.
You know,
I have my public position,
but that's,
that doesn't mean I don't have sympathy for you.
I went to the organizers of the event.
I had them cut that part out of the tape because there's no reason this person
should be exposed to ridicule.
And then I had coffee with the person next morning to ensure that the person was
doing okay emotionally.
Okay.
That's not coming from a place of I don't care about people.
This is coming from a place of these are important,
vital public conversations and shutting down those conversations by saying that
I don't care about a human being that I don't care about what happens to people
is the nastiest form of no platforming because it's not just saying,
you know,
this is a replatform of your views because your views are so terrible and so
awful.
It's saying that your views are inherently evil.
Yeah,
they're inherently sociopath and you are too.
And you are too.
And that's,
and that's something that I think is actually a form of assholery beyond
comprehension.
Also don't think that
you can care for people.
I think that you can care for individuals.
And I mean one of the things that's been characterizing the tour that we've been
doing is that like when I'm lecturing,
I don't lecture to the audience or lecture do individuals and I'm not lecturing
to them either.
That's that's the wrong way because I always include myself in the discussion.
So if we're talking about ethical principles and how they might be,
um,
uh,
what would you call it?
Put forward or,
or founded more,
more solidly than,
I'm always including myself in the list of perpetrators who need some
improvement.
Right?
So it's just discussing with people one at a time,
even though they happen to be very large audiences.
And then when I see people afterwards,
cause I meet about 150 people after each talk,
then I get not a huge amount of time,
but enough time to make personal contact with each person.
And I'm very careful to do that extremely carefully because I'm very happy
through there.
And they often tell me a story about,
you know,
how they were suffering in some way or things,
words set right in their life and that they've been trying to develop a vision
to aim high at something that's worth aiming at,
which is part of the advantage of hierarchies,
right?
Which though,
which is something we should talk about because you can't aim at something
without privileging it over something else.
And if you don't have any of the day math and you don't have any purpose in your
life,
and that's a bloody catastrophe.
So anyways,
they come up with a vision and they're trying to be more responsible.
And then there's the individualism aspect of this is,
you know,
I've,
I've outlined to people that there are take responsibility for themselves,
which is not the same thing as to be individually selfish and to do that in a
way that also makes them responsible for their family and to do that in a way
that also makes them responsible for the community.
So the individualism isn't the selfish individualism that the leftists or
criticism criticizing by any stretch of the imagination.
It's the individual positioned in an iterated game,
right?
That includes them as individual stretched across time.
So there's already a collective in that in some sense.
And then them in relationship to family and the community,
but they're stemming from the individual,
which I think is part and parcel of the Judeo Christian enlightenment
philosophy.
Anyways,
these people come and tell me this story and they say they were in a bad place
and that things have improved a lot and they're kind of sad about the bad place
part of visual,
visibly upset often.
And then they tell me how things are improved,
improved and they're really happy about that.
And it's very touching and emotional and that's where the,
that's where caring takes place.
That's right.
At the level of the individual.
I went into a whole foods yesterday and this happens quite often.
So I was there and two of the guys from behind the meat counter came out
separately and they said that they had been watching my lectures and one of them
talked about the fact that you know,
he has a seven year old son and that he wants to do right by him.
Then he's been looking really hard for ethical and moral guidance and that he's
been reading and listening to my book and concentrating on the parts about
telling the truth and not lying.
And I'm having these conversations with people one at a time about them striving
hard to develop an ethical,
philosophically grounded ethical perspective.
You know,
and it's so interesting to see this happening and to see who's doing
well.
This is,
this is,
I think an important point is that I get asked a lot because I do get so much
criticism and flack.
I get asked a lot,
have I ever been confronted in public cause I got in public,
you know,
with my family to Disneyland,
went on Thanksgiving to Disneyland and I got go see accosted,
not not Costa,
but people came up to me because they like my stuff or they enjoy it and they
want to take pictures.
Probably happen 35 to 40 times over the course of the day.
And they asked me have I ever,
has there ever been a situation where somebody came up to you and said something
mean or nasty?
Yeah,
I can't think of one.
Yeah.
I can't think of one time this has ever happened now online.
That's all I get.
And so the point here is that when it comes to individuals who are affected and
who actually,
and who actually feel good or bad about you.
Yeah,
it's a collective mob mentality that allows people to protest you and then
protest me.
And then that is picked up.
The mob mentality is picked up by individual journalists who are,
who see themselves as sort of champions of the people broadly but not champions
of individuals.
Because there you still can't find the individual who's been victimized by
Jordan Peterson.
You still can't find the individual who's been victimized by Dave Rubin or the
individual who's been victimized by Ben Shapiro.
You can't find those people.
So instead what it becomes is,
oh,
it's a broader group that's victimized,
but none of those people have ever come to me personally and said,
you victimize me.
You hurt me.
Because they can't name a situation in which this has happened.
I always love,
I always love when they say that were radicalizing people and it's like if I
open up my inbox,
I'm getting emails from all sorts of people,
usually on the right who say that they were a little more extreme on the right
and that because they see a decent liberal who will treat them with respect.
They've modified some of their opinions.
But what do you think about this just at a,
at a psychological level,
the disconnect between what seems to be happening in the real world on a day to
day basis and the way a huge amount of people are behaving online.
What do you think is psychologically?
Boy,
that's a tough one.
I mean,
it could easily be like if you think of of venues like Twitter,
let's take Twitter as an example.
We don't understand.
We don't really understand much about how people communicate periods
psychologically.
One of the things that psychologists do know is that if there's any distancing
between you and a person.
So for example,
if you're inside a car,
you're much more likely to act in an impulsive,
in hostile manner.
And that,
because one of the things that seems to mitigate against that impulsive
hostility is whatever mechanisms kick in when you're face to face with someone.
So those might be mechanisms that are associated with the Nate sympathy,
for example.
And so that regulates your behavior.
And because most of the time in our evolutionary history,
you were interacting directly one on one with someone that seemed to work out
quite well.
Caveman were doing it with they,
no,
no.
They had to,
they had to carve in,
in salts into the,
into walls.
And that,
that took a lot of time.
And so,
but on Twitter like it could easily be,
I read this little article here at Wabash showing what words needed to be in
content for those to be most likely retweeted and they were almost all high
level negative emotion words.
And so we could be,
you have this huge pool of people and then it might be that only the person
who's in a bad mood and is irritated that day or a sort of chronically like that
or dispositionally like that,
let's say,
and who is specifically angry about something that they saw right then is likely
to tweet.
And so that gives you this tremendously skewed view of,
of,
of the,
of the consensus because you assume like if you is,
if there's a hundred people that show up in a mall outside your door,
you assume that there's more than a hundred people mad at you right there.
There are representative of a much larger group on,
on Twitter.
You can't tell if the 30 people who say snarky things,
especially anonymously to you,
you can't tell if they're representative at all and they're likely not.
And you know that that very narrow bandwidth,
that 140 or 280 characters might also be something that really facilitates
angry,
impulsive responding.
And so we don't understand any of this psychological and I think there's
something else happening too.
And that is that both Twitter and Facebook,
all social media is basically something different in human history in the sense
that it's just a crowd without a purpose.
So it's a crowd looking for a purpose,
meaning that throughout human history we actually had to have face to face
interactions with people.
The only reason you would show up in a crowd is the crowd had a purpose.
So where were you typically doing this as you were going to a church,
right?
Everybody was there to worship.
Everybody was there with a common goal in mind,
right?
You were a member of the army until the,
there's a common goal in mind anytime you were getting together was because
there was a party.
So everybody was there for the party.
Twitter is legitimately people waking up and just I want to interact with other
humans.
There are no other humans around.
And so I'm here and you're here and we're all here and look,
somebody just sends something odd.
There's a common purpose.
Let's jump on that.
And then there's this backslapping effect of the person said something and I
mean we all use Twitter,
so we all know that if you are the most dangerous thing about Twitter,
the most eight,
if I could do anything with Twitter,
I would get rid of the mentions tab.
The reason being,
because if you are a,
if you're just a human behavior,
it encourages bad behavior,
especially because it encourages you to be looking and seeing how people are
responding to you.
Because as human beings,
we're constantly looking to see how people are responding to us.
And so this is just generally a good thing,
right?
It's generally a good thing except that it's,
it's an ego machine.
Yeah.
That's the down side because the key,
one of the keys to being a good person is to recognize most people aren't
thinking about you 95% of the time,
right?
You're not that important as a human.
And so in order for you to be important,
actually do something important.
But because Twitter functions in such a way that all you get is that feedback
loop,
it encourages you more and more to look for more of that feedback makes you feel
good.
I mean,
you get a little endorphin rush every time there's a nice comment about you,
you refresh,
you refresh for more nice comments.
That doesn't happen in real life.
There's never a situation,
real life in which that happens.
And when it does,
it's a major life event.
It's a wedding,
it's Bar Mitzvah,
right?
Something where people are collectively celebrating you.
But on Twitter,
everybody is collectively celebrating everybody else.
And the people who issued the strongest opinions are the people who receive both
the most condemnation and most celebrations
we weird way,
not that we want people to go into their bubbles,
but are these town squares almost?
They're almost too big to actually ever function properly.
So every week there's another story where Jack says,
I'm going to get rid of the likes,
or I'm going to get rid of follower accounts.
And they're always trying to float these ideas to manipulate how we all behave
with each other.
But in an odd way,
having everyone from everywhere on these platforms really doesn't make sense in
some bizarre way.
I'm not saying that we should be in separate places where there is no community.
Yeah,
Ben's right.
So it's like we need something that has community I think.
But then the danger is that we ended up in our little echo,
right.
I mean the,
the,
they're the need.
It's fascinating because if you're looking at other places on the Internet,
just structurally,
the way that the community works is a little bit different.
The way that it works or it used to work 10 years ago,
uh,
when people actually visited websites directly was that you'd have something
like at national review the corner.
And it was a bunch of people,
you know,
like us sitting around and discussing ideas back and forth and back and forth,
like a group blog.
Yeah.
And it was restricted to the people who were discussing the ideas and then below
that video game board or anything.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then below that you'd have the comment section,
which was all about those particular conversations because Twitter is
fragmented.
There's no actual conversation taking place on Twitter.
There's me saying something and you responding to it and me not responding to
you mostly and then be tweeting another thought and then you responding to it
and the idea of having a long form every time it happens on Twitter,
at the end of the conversation you find someone saying,
this isn't the appropriate place to have a long form conversation for,
we're going to do that.
We'd be on a podcast with wait.
Right?
We'd be writing each other letters like that.
This isn't,
this isn't the way to do that and even when I'm discussing with my peers,
even when I'm talking with people on the left who I talk with on the phone,
instead of having a conversation on Twitter about the topic,
I will call,
pick up the phone and call them and have the conversation because he can't have
a good conversation on Twitter.
You just can't.
How much
is connected to one of the things that you've brought up in many of the
lectures,
which is that we're just getting information so much faster.
Right now.
We can not only just open up our phone and have basically the world right there,
but we can listen to podcasts in double speed,
which would be listening to Shapiro in double speed.
You go back in time actually.
But yeah,
I listen to you at half speed a little faster.
Um,
but that the,
the,
just the,
the nature of the technology,
how it's just speeding up our ability to take in information that maybe we
haven't evolved fast.
Well,
it's also more taking in kind of pseudo information because it looks like
information,
but it's really low resolution.
And so you get a lot of it,
but it's not,
it's not real knowledge.
It's like,
well,
there was a funny New Yorker cartoon where wife asked her husband,
do you know that or do you just Google?
No.
It.
Right.
And so,
and the,
but the,
the,
the thing about those,
those,
those shallow media,
um,
interactions is that you also don't have to take any responsibility for them,
you know,
especially if you're anonymous.
And that also brings out the worst in people,
you know,
and,
and the,
the trolling phenomena in,
one of the things you notice about children for example,
is if children don't get enough good attention,
they'll certainly go after bad attention because the fundamental human currency
is attention.
And it's,
it's one thing to be hated,
but it's another thing entirely to be ignored.
And I would say generally speaking,
if you put people in a corner and you made them choose,
you know,
if they were,
if they had knowledge that was transparent to themselves,
he said,
what would you rather be ignored or hated?
They'd take hate it because at least then you exist because you exist,
at least in some part in your relationship to other people.
And so some of the bad behavior is,
is rewarded precisely for that reason is that it does draw attention.
And that does make you signify,
I mean,
you think about the people who do highness crimes,
like the,
the school shooters,
people like that who do these things that are almost inconceivable,
a huge part of the drive for that.
His fantasies about notoriety and,
and,
Yup.
And the emergence from obscurity and anonymity.
Even though it's,
it's notorious,
it's hatred.
The idea is I'd rather be dead and infamous then alive and anonymous.
Yeah.
By the way,
you,
I think we're one of the first websites to say we're not going to publish in
these people.
Yeah.
And then we're giving them exactly what they want.
Exactly.
Like the,
there've been,
I don't want to take credit as like the first,
because there were several,
I'm trying their names escape me,
but there are other people who have been promoting this for awhile.
But yeah,
I was late to it.
We should've done it earlier.
And I told him
the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation about that about 10 years ago,
about the idea that publicizing the names of these killers is precisely one of
the mechanisms that ensures that it will continue to happen.
And there's no doubt about that.
Now,
how to,
how to mitigate against that
complicated.
I mean,
and then that does tie to a deeper conversation that did you see this?
This study is from the CDC that came out of that again for the second straight
year.
Life expectancy in the United States dropped.
So he had consistent life expectancy increases in the United States for 150
years.
And now for the first time in American modern American history,
life expectancy is now dropped for two years in a row.
And that's specifically due to two phenomena.
One is the increase in heroin overdoses and the other is suicide,
both as suicide is now at record rates in the modern era.
And we had 70,000 heroin overdoses,
LPO,
Oprah overdoses last year.
Uh,
I think it was 50,000 the year before.
And so you're starting to see life expectancy decline.
There's a crisis of meaning and that's why,
and I think that part of the resistance to particularly I think Jordan,
but I think also to me and to anyone else in the IDW cause at least searching
for meaning is that the left has been saying for a long time that we found the
meaning,
right?
The meaning was do what you want to do,
meaning was no responsibility.
Do what you want to do.
That's the meaning.
The meaning is rebelling against the system.
And when it turns out that a lot of people don't find meaning in that,
that there is,
in my perspective,
a God shaped hole in people's heart that is being filled by hatred and
polarization and tribalism.
Or that you just can't do it forever.
No one can maintain that,
that level forever of trying to tear everything down.
And it's also,
there's also,
there's,
there's nothing in it,
especially as your opponent weakens,
you know,
this is,
we,
we thought maybe we'd talk a little bit over what hierarchy.
So you know,
the thing about,
one of the things a hierarchy does is,
is fundamentally is put some things above other things.
When you think,
well the left criticize the left criticism of that,
which is a valid criticism is that if you were wrecked a hierarchy,
well let,
let me,
let me step one step back.
We'll,
we'll walk through this in,
in a bit of a sequence.
Okay.
So the first proposition would be we do have real problems because people suffer
and like we have real problems.
Then we would also like to solve them and that solutions do exist.
And that if you have a solution and then you implemented socially and so you
have to get people to cooperate and compete around the solution,
you're going to produce a hierarchy.
And if the hierarchies valid than the people who are the best at producing those
solution to the problem,
we're going to lead the hierarchy.
Okay.
So that would be a conservative right wing position.
It's like we need hierarchies.
They,
they privilege values and they're necessary to solve problems.
And there is a relationship between the ability to solve the problem.
And the structure of the hierarchy.
Okay.
So the,
when we'd say that's true in hierarchies are functioning well.
Okay.
So that's the right wing viewpoint.
And then the left wingers would say,
wait a second,
your hierarchy gets rigid over time.
And also fi's and can be by people who use power instead of competence to
dominate it.
And they do that unfairly and they work the structure of the hierarchy.
And that makes it difficult for people to gain entry,
including talented people.
And then the hierarchy itself as a structure has a problem because dispossessed
people tend to stack up at the bottom and that all seems relevant and true.
Right?
So,
so then,
then you could say,
well you need the right because you need the hierarchies and,
and,
and they need to be implemented.
And that's what managers and administrators do.
That's what conscientious people do cause they're hierarchically oriented and
it's a very efficient way of operating.
And people are actually happier within hierarchies because there's an
identifiable chain of command.
But then the left has its position,
which is,
yeah,
but you got to watch out for the dispossessed because they're the majority and
you have to make sure the thing doesn't degenerate towards tyranny.
So then I think the political discussion is the left and the right constantly
eyeing each other to make sure that the hierarchical structures maintain their
good health and so,
and that's why freedom of speech is necessary.
Okay.
So the,
now the,
the issue with that,
let's see if I can get back to where I was.
I was going with this to begin with.
Oh yes.
The issue with that is that if you are just a rebel,
you say,
well we're going to criticize the system,
whatever that is.
So that's a very vague thing to begin with.
You demolish that value hierarchy and,
and the idea of value hierarchies as such.
But then that puts you in a terrible conundrum.
And this is what I've been focusing on in my public lectures,
is that if you accept the essential idea that life is suffering and life is
suffering tainted by malevolence,
which I think is an even more accurate formulation,
you have a fundamental existential problem and that's the suffering.
And then you need a meaning to set against that to,
to,
to fortify you against the catastrophe.
So,
and if you demolish the hierarchies,
then you have no meaning.
There's nothing to strive for.
And without that meaning you're anxious and overwhelmed by definition.
We know that neuropsychologically because purpose boxes you in right at the,
it gives you a game to play and rules to follow and then purpose gives you
something to aim at and positive emotion.
And so the problem with what the left is offering,
and I think this is actually the kind of problem that Sam Harris and the atheist
types of running into too,
is it's like,
well,
okay,
where's the purpose?
Well,
we don't have one.
It's just rebellion against the unfair hierarchy.
It's like,
yeah,
but the hierarchy also provides you with value.
Well that's okay.
It's cost is so high,
we're going to demolish the hierarchy.
Well then you're left with nothing.
Well,
but no,
you're not left with nothing because your left,
what you're left with is an inalienable suffering.
So nothing that's the suicide.
And I think that the,
the left solution to that has been intersectionality main.
What they've done is they've just taken that higher,
they've taken the hierarchy and they've said the hierarchy is bad because it's
ossified and it's terrible and it's not just that they've destroyed the
hierarchy and then we are all leveled is that they've inverted the hierarchy in
certain ways.
That merit itself has become a sign that you are an exploiter.
Yes,
right.
That if you are that you feel are on the top of the hierarchy,
then it's because you did something wrong to get there and you hurt someone to
get there.
And therefore the last shall be first we're going to just take this triangle.
I'm going to flip it upside down.
So that way the people who are at the bottom or at the top.
So I think that,
I think there's something absolutely fundamental there too,
because I'd been trying to understand what the core issue is that drives the
pathological left.
And I think it is the story of Cain and Abel fundamentally is that it's,
it's jealousy of the successful and,
and the worst kind of successful person as it turns out,
it from a jealousy perspective,
think speaking psychologically,
it's like if you got your power arbitrarily,
if you inherited it or you got it unfairly,
well you're kind of annoying,
but you're not that annoying because you're not that good.
You're just lucky break.
And so I can be jealous of you because you're lucky and that's unfair,
but you're just as reprehensible as me.
Right?
But then let's take the alternative position.
Let's say that I'm not taking responsibility for my life in any sense,
and I'm not bearing any more load.
And it turns out that not only are you successful,
but you're competent and good.
Well then you're a real enemy because you're a judge under those circumstances.
Right?
Because it's,
it's your goodness in some sense,
your competence and your goodness,
that's really showing me in a negative light.
And instead of wanting to contend with that and to see myself reflected badly in
your mirror,
then I'm going to make the accusation that everything you've done is merely a
consequence of power.
And,
and even deep,
more deeply,
I'm going to criticize the idea of merit and competence itself.
Yep.
Because that gets me out of my self loathing,
say,
well,
there's none of that's real.
None of that merit.
None of that competence is real.
And none of the failure that I'm experiencing is a consequence of my own
inaction.
Yep.
It's all someone and then saw someone else's fault and then I get to be
justified in going after them as well.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's icing on the cake.
They can enable stories.
I mean,
it's explicit about this.
this isn't even buried in the text,
right.
That's explicit.
I mean,
God specifically says to Cain,
Tim Shell,
right.
You have the capacity to overcome.
Yes.
Right.
And cater towards that.
And then he goes and kills ego.
Yup.
And that's the whole idea.
That
crux of that story is that,
and because cane complaints to God,
right?
Says what?
He basically says something along the life's not fair.
What happened?
That's right.
How dare you set up a universe like this where I'm breaking myself in half,
attempting to,
you know,
to thrive and everything's going against me and I have my brother who,
who everything that he touches turns to gold.
And that's right.
God says to him,
directly,
look to yourself.
It's,
it's your inadequacy that's driving this and it's the last thing that came,
wants to hear,
and they tie in.
That's what makes a murderer.
And I think that that is the last thing that most people want to hear.
That's what's so attractive about a leftist ideology that doesn't actually
provide any sense of meaning outside of the victim hood called is it this
feeling that the last thing that people want to hear generally is look to your
look to yourself first.
It's a lot easier to,
I mean,
but you,
but it's also bad parenting,
right?
It's funny
because one of the things that's happening in my lectures is because I'd doing
something different,
you know,
instead of saying,
see,
I think one of the things that the conservative types do wrong with regards to
responsibility is that they,
they,
they conceptualize it too rigidly into terms of duty and should,
and that that's,
uh,
that's true.
But it's also a mistake because what I've been suggesting to people is that no,
you don't understand,
is that all the meaning in your life is going to come as a consequence of
accepting responsibility.
It's not merely a matter of duty.
It's that you need this sustaining meaning because otherwise you,
you suffer stupidly and you get bitter and you get resentful and you get cruel
and you get homicidal and you get genocidal.
That's the whole pathway.
And so that's,
that's a catastrophe.
That's hell.
And so if you don't have something meaningful to pursue,
to,
to set against that,
that's,
that's your,
that's the degeneration of nihilism.
Okay.
So where do you find the response?
Where do you find the meeting say,
well,
you look at people that you admire and almost all the people you admire,
people who take on a heavy burden of responsibility.
And if the responsibility is associated with the value hierarchy,
so you're trying to pursue something of ultimate value.
So that's the responsibility that gives you meaning.
And so you can talk to people about taking responsibility for their,
um,
inadequacy if you point out to them that who they could be as much better than
who they are so that there's a trajectory.
And so that the idea of taking on responsibility even for their own inadequacies
and errors is all of a sudden associated with hope and not with only
condemnation.
And that works.
And that like when,
when I lay out that line of argument in the lectures and Dave's seen this
multiple times,
it's always the case that the Lecture Hall School Silent People are absolutely
riveted on that idea.
And this is interesting,
I did an interview at Tucker Carlson hydrolase inherit.
He also,
and one of the things that we talked about was,
and what people should do in dying towns,
they're in areas where the industry has left.
What should they do?
They're experiencing difficulty.
And I was saying that telling people that the jobs are coming back falsely is
not going to actually do anything for them.
That the only thing that you're guaranteed in America or in a free country is
the adventure,
right?
That's what you're guaranteed.
And that's also what makes life meaningful is that sense of adventure.
That's what America was built on,
right?
That's the fundamental command.
The very first command that Abraham has ever given is get up,
leave the land of your fathers,
were it,
and go someplace where you,
I'm not going to tell you where you're going.
You're just going to go there.
And then when you get there,
maybe you'll know.
Right?
And that's,
and that's that.
But I,
I think that one of the areas,
Jordan,
where you and I,
uh,
I think it'd be interesting to drill down is when it comes to directing toward
the purpose,
how do we define what the purpose is?
Because I think one of the things that's been difficult in the west,
at least since the death of the Judeo Christian value system in many ways,
or at least the the sort of we're running on the fumes of the Judaeo Christian
value system is the truth,
but since the,
since the decline of the importance in many people's minds of that value system,
the decline of Biblical living has been this idea,
you can create your own meaning.
Yeah.
Right.
You just did that.
If you find something that you truly care about and then you pursue that thing
that you
truly care about,
this will bring you happiness and that may be true for a certain number of
people,
but the vast majority of people are incredibly crappy at coming up with their
own meetings.
Yeah.
There has to be something that is out there that is discoverable in order for it
to be discussed with the psychoanalysts.
That's why y'all like young so much because that was,
that's what made him such an astute critic of nature because nature believed we
had to create our own values.
But the psychoanalyst starting with Freud started to note that the values were
actually built in.
And Freud saw that first of all in dreams,
right?
And then young young took that apart in associated the dreams with the myths and
said,
no,
you don't understand is that the values are built in.
You don't create them,
you can rediscover them.
And that's the resurrection of the father from the,
from,
from the,
from the belly of the beast.
This raise a question as to a,
and w and I have discussed this before,
is where exactly that moral system comes from.
So cons obviously talks about the idea that uh,
you know,
he,
he believes in God because of the starry sky above and the moral law with it.
Yeah,
you can write,
you can discover all this within.
I am not convinced the human beings can actually discover meaning within,
because if that were true,
then the prosperity and liberalism and human rights and value for individuals
and all the things that we associate with the good stuff in the west,
that would have been universal.
And it is not in fact universal.
It arose at a certain time at a particular place associated with a particular
value system.
This is why when people ask me about why I think the revelation is necessary,
why it's important is because I think that without you,
you're going to have to make these fundamental assumption to get from point a to
point B,
you're going to have to make fundamental assumptions at point day.
Now you can either get that from revelation or he can just assume it and then
try to explain where those assumptions came from.
Or you can just pretend those assumptions don't exist,
which is I think actually what Sam sort of does.
Uh,
and I,
I hate to criticize him in his absence,
but I think the Tam sort of just assumed that when he says things like,
we're here for the greater flourishing of human beings.
Yeah.
You actually have to define every one of those terms that are a bunch of
assumptions baked into what all of that means that he's making.
And I'm not sure that Sam will acknowledge she's making them.
Um,
but the,
that's why to me,
and this is sort of thesis of my book next year,
the,
the West is built on the,
the basic revelations of Jerusalem.
Meaning you,
human beings are made in God's image with individual value and with individual
purpose and with a collective purpose where we get together and we pursue living
in a more virtuous way.
And that's one pole.
And the other pole is the reason of Greece where we have the capacity to look at
the world around us and draw conclusions from that world.
And on those Poles are built all of modern science,
our bill to all of economics are built the free speech and free and free lives
that we live right now.
And I think that we have been gradually over the last 200 years chipping away at
both of those polls,
Jerusalem in terms of revelation and Athens in terms of reason which we've
abandoned for postmodernism.
And that's just private support
in a weird way is this the failure of the enlightenment liberals,
all the people that I grew up loving and caring about and the people that I
still admire that and this,
this little sliver of liberals that still remained,
that haven't bought into leftist dogma,
but that aren't necessarily
religious per say or believe in these stories,
but really they,
they believe it comes from the enlightenment period.
I think that's a good observation that this is sort of their failure.
I don't mean I don't want to,
I'm not blaming their arrogance,
I would say,
because even people,
there's not enough,
there's not enough in the secular world to fight to fight this new release.
That's where I'm sort of finding myself right now,
which is an incredibly uncomfortable place.
I come from a much more atheist perspective obviously than you and certainly
where you are and yet I can see what the future is now and it's like there's
nothing left over there and we do need some fundamental to you because that's
just the position [inaudible] without the mythos underneath it.
Exactly.
You see?
Is that you and Sam,
while it's where I disagree with people like and Pancakes,
I mean I'm an enlightenment guy,
but the thing is is that when,
not when I look backwards in time,
you know what,
what,
what people like Harrison pinker attribute to the enlightenment.
I see as the enlightenment being the latest flowering of a process that was
indescribably older than that is exactly right.
And in the,
and in the historical sense,
certainly grounded in the religious traditions,
but and then from my perspective grounded in something that's biological,
that's far deeper than that.
Like,
like our true proclivity towards admiration for competence and reciprocity.
And I do think that has to be socialized back to your point.
So I want,
one of the things Dave mentioned before we started this was that we could have a
bit of a conversation about the difference between Judaism and Christianity in
terms of,
I'd love to get to that.
I do want to make one comment on the,
on the neo enlightenment stuff.
So,
I mean,
I will say that there is a full chapter in my book that is specifically about
the views of a lot of people who I love.
You know,
Sam and Michael Shermer and Hank are and the whole Neil enlightenment strain of
thought that I think kind of includes general boulevard on the conservative
side.
Yeah.
And I love these guys and I feel intellectually I feel more comfortable with
that position,
but I realize I'm just being whittled away.
You can't hold much.
So here's my basic view and my basic thesis is that there are two views of the
enlightenment.
One is that in general Goldberg's words,
it was the miracle that dependent as head of sprang from nowhere suddenly reason
dominated over revelation and it crushed revelation.
And in the wake of that crushing came the full flowering of economics and
humanity and freedom and liberalism and that those things were opposed reason
and revelation.
This where that these words,
and not only they weren't intention,
they weren't full,
simply opposed because there's truth,
that reason and revelation our intention.
But it is also true that certain assumptions undergird the assumptions of
reason.
In order for you to believe that reason exists and isn't just ate and
evolutionarily favorable firing of neurons,
then you have to,
if you have,
if you like,
I think that Sam's position,
that objective truth exists in the absence of anything remotely approaching a,
uh,
a system of,
of assumptions is unsupportable.
It's completely unsupportable.
I think that,
I think because you are built to create more little copies of you,
right?
I mean this is evolutionarily speaking,
what you are created to do,
how that has to do with discovering objective truth is I don't really beyond me.
Uh,
so,
and,
and what has to do with the existence of objective truth in any,
in any case,
the enlightenment is based on certain fundamental assumptions.
It's based on the idea that you can act as an individual freely by making
rational decisions in a predictable world of laws,
right?
All,
all of,
every one of those assumptions is ungrounded in,
in a world of pure scientific determinism.
It just doesn't,
it doesn't exist.
So the [inaudible] eight itself,
what happened?
And so there is,
what I'm seeing is that the enlightenment,
the enlightenment was,
and I think that you see this in college,
who's d count sees all of this.
He sees that this struggle is coming and so he attempts to reinject religion and
spirituality and God back into a moral system without actually saying so.
Right.
Cons is not actually an atheist.
Cons is actually trying to create a rational basis for Christian revelation and
Christian reasoning so that he can avoid the trap of having to cite the Bible,
but he can say that all of this makes sense anyway.
Well,
that's why I see this as the failure of the modern liberals because it's like
even with some of some of our IDW crew that most of these people,
most of us come from the left originally and it's like,
well,
the position we're at now is there's no one on the left that will talk to any of
us without attacking us or doing any of the usual tricks.
Now we've got all of these people like you and Prager and the rest of them that
are willing to talk to us,
willing to debate all,
you know,
all of this.
And I still see a hesitancy because people,
it's so,
it's so sort of built into people that conservatives are evil or that even
thinking about the world through a religious lens or anything like that is
somehow evil or dumb or,
or something like that.
And it's like,
I just can't play by that.
You mean?
I think that the psychoanalysts and,
and some of the neuroscientists that I knew to,
the ones that were more informed about,
about emotion and motivation and also interested in dreams and instincts.
So those would be the neuroscientists who are more concerned with emotion a
rather than the cognitive types.
The cognitive types are like the rationalist in the psychology field.
They're very,
um,
open to the two.
They were surprisingly open to union ideas.
You know,
the idea that,
you know,
our,
our rationality is embedded inside our emotions and that's all embedded inside
of our motivations.
And now it's all embedded inside our bodies by,
so rationality isn't this,
this,
what would you call it?
Free Floating,
uh,
soul in some sense that's capable of contemplating the objective world,
but something that's deeply embedded inside all sorts of other structures on
which its validity as dependent.
One of the things the psychoanalysts were so good at pointing out and that I
think is in accordance with the neuropsychological evidence,
is that your rationality is bounded by the dream.
And it's literally that way because if you are deprived of dreaming,
which kind of puts you in the mythic world,
then you go,
you literally lose your mind.
There has to be continual dialogue between revelation that would be associated
with the dreamworld and rationality or rationality cannot sustain itself.
And the reason for that is that as far as I can tell,
is that the assumptions of rationality are in the myth in the mythos,
which was the argument that I was trying to make continually with Sam.
And so then the question is what constitutes the myth goes?
And so you,
one of your points was,
well there's this idea that human beings are made in the image of God.
And so I've been thinking about that a lot.
And so my sense is something like this is that,
and you tell me what you think about this.
Okay,
so you wake up in the morning and your consciousness emerges from nothing in
some sense.
And what you see in front of you,
you aren't determined like a clock in what you're going to do that day.
In fact,
your consciousness is in fact that part of you that deals with what is not yet
determined because all the things that you do that are fundamentally habitual
and deterministic are unconscious.
They turn into habit and you don't have conscious control over them.
So consciousness seems to be that element that deals with what has not yet been
determined.
Okay,
so you wake up in the morning and what you confront as far as I'm concerned,
he has potential.
There's a,
there's a field of potential in front of you and that that's the future.
Whatever that is,
that potential,
it's,
it's what couldn't be.
And what is not yet.
And then as a consequence of the choices that you make guided by your ethical
aims,
then you transform that potential into actuality.
And you literally do that with your consciousness.
And I think that's the reflection of the image of God in Matt.
And I think that's what's put forward in the earliest sections of genesis
because that's what God does,
right?
God is a structure he confronts nothingness with,
with something approximating consciousness,
the logos and the extracts out order from potential.
And then one of the things that's interesting about that,
there's,
there's repetition of the idea in,
in genesis that if you confront potential with truth,
so that's the logos,
let's say with truth,
then the order that you produce is good.
So there's a,
so which is a really interesting ethical claim,
right?
You take this potential,
you interact with it morally,
the consequences of interacting and morally is that you produce reality and the
reality that you produce is good.
And then human beings are a microcosm of that,
that that Sienna,
that,
that's exactly right.
I mean,
I think that the,
this is the kind of philosophy in philosophy terms.
This is basically the argument about the amenities and Thomas Aquinas who are
making this Ireland basically at the same time is that,
you know,
at the beginning when it says [inaudible] she came at such a mind bad hire.
It's that,
that in the beginning God created the heavens and the earth.
What makes human beings in the image of God is our creative capacity.
And the creative capacity is the ability to transform through an act of will.
Something that was not into something that is,
and that's what the beginning chapters of genesis are.
It's God taking things and just making them.
And then what makes them good is that these things are,
this is the Aristotelian part,
is the,
is that these things are directed to our purpose toward a purpose.
So what the,
the idea of Greek rationality,
what distinguishes
it from other ideas of rationality is that Greek rationality is based on a
fundamental premise,
which is that you can look at a thing and the thing was made for something,
right?
So if you look at,
if you look at a glass,
the glass was made to hold liquid and you can tell that because that's the
nature of the glass.
So there's nothing in science is a glass was made to hold liquid is just a piece
of of glass that is made in a certain particular shape.
But we as human beings know that this glass was made to hold liquid and that we
can look at the universe in the same way that we can.
We can say what was the purpose of this thing?
And that's why when God says that something is good,
the,
the use of the word good in,
in Eras Tutelian thought is good,
is fit for the purpose.
What makes you a good pilot,
for example,
is your capacity to land a plane.
What makes this a good glass?
Its capacity to hold liquid.
And what makes you a good person is your capacity to use rationality in pursuit
of virtue and to transform the world around you and doing so.
That's what makes you a good person.
And so when it says in the beginning of genesis that God has the tree of good
and evil and that you are the knowledge of good and evil and it's a sin to eat
from the knowledge of good and evil.
My understanding of that is that what human beings did is instead of trying to
function according to figuring out what God's purpose for things was,
trying to figure out what the universe was to be used for in accordance with
reality,
we decided to super impose our own vision of what reality should be in a moral
sense and that there's a fundamental disconnect or,
and it leads to suffering.
All right,
so let's,
let's dumb this down for just one second because I want to ask a question that I
know you don't like getting when we get in the Q and A's,
but I think it would be interesting for the three of us to sort of kick it
around here,
which is for the average person that that's listening to this,
they can only take in so many of these ideas and so much of this right,
and I think that actually is most people that are just living their lives.
I think a certain set of people are listening to both of you and going,
all right,
these two guys think that some guys talking to them from the sky,
I mean,
I know this is,
this is the most,
I know why this,
you don't love this question because it's so ridiculous.
We oversimplified,
but how,
how do you get to those people then for the people that think,
well,
wait a minute,
what do you,
what are you talking about?
Shapiro loves facts over feelings,
but he's talking about this imaginary sky guy that wrote this book and Blah,
blah,
blah.
What do you think is the,
is there a psychological trick to sort of get people over that Hump if you
wanted them to start exploring stem of this?
Well,
you know what I mean,
we can,
we can do the high level stuff for hours and hours,
but,
but eventually it just keeps getting to a sort of smaller and smaller place that
people can,
can get to.
All right.
So that's,
so that's so hard question and so I'll,
I'll try to address it this way.
So there's a line in the New Testament where Christ says that no one comes to
the father except through him,
which is a hell of a thing for anyone to say.
I mean there's a lot of statements in the New Testament that are strikingly
strange in that manner.
I am the way and the truth and the life,
that's another one.
It's associated with the same idea.
Yeah.
And we'll get to some of the,
yeah.
Okay.
So,
so here's,
here's the idea and,
and it,
it bears on your question,
although I don't exactly know how it's as if there's a spirit at the bottom of
things that is,
that is involved in the,
in the,
in the bringing to being of everything.
So like,
so for example,
people talk about evolution as a random process,
but that's not true.
It's not true.
The mutations are random,
but there's also a lot of sources,
other sources of genetic variant variation.
But the selection mechanisms are not random.
So now then the question is what are the selection mechanisms?
So I'm going to have to go a bunch of places.
Well,
well here's one selection mechanism.
It's like,
so human females are very sexually selective.
That's why you have twice as many female ancestors as male ancestor.
So the male failure rate for reproduction is twice that of the females.
Okay.
So the question is,
well,
how is it that males succeed differentially?
And the first answer is,
well,
females reject.
If human females reject,
but then the question might be,
well they reject on the basis of what and the answer is,
well it's something like competence.
And then the question is,
well,
how is competence defined?
And then the answer to that is,
well men put themselves in hierarchies and they vote on each other's competence.
And it's really counterintuitive in some sense from an evolutionary perspective
because you'd have to ask yourself,
why would men put the selves in positions where they elevate some men in status
and then give them a huge reproductive advantage given that that's to their
reproductive disadvantage in in some sense.
Okay.
And there are reasons.
Part of that might be,
let's say you decided to follow the best leader in a battle.
Well then you don't die.
Like he might get all the women but you don't die it.
So at least you're still in the game.
And it might be the same if you're following the greatest hunter and the
greatest hunter wouldn't be the person who is best at bringing down the game.
It would be the person who is best at bringing down the game and sharing it.
And organizing the next hunt and all of that,
right?
And so men will organize themselves into groups and privileged certain men,
and that puts them ahead in the reproductive hierarchy.
And so what that means to some degree is that there's a a spirit of masculinity
that's shaping the entire structure of human evolutionary history.
That's what that means.
And then I think,
okay,
well that might just be a biological epi phenomenon.
And so it would be a spirit that meant it's the spirit of positive masculinity
that manifests itself across [inaudible] ages,
millions of years perhaps.
And it actually has shaped our consciousness actually.
And so you can think about that as a figure,
and it would be the figure that emerges.
It's like,
it's like the,
it's like this.
It's like the essential spirit of all the great men who defined what greatness
constituted.
That's a spirit.
Okay?
Now that's a purely biological explanation.
You can say,
well,
that's God.
For all intents and purposes,
you might have an image of that build right into you.
Even the sense that you can experience something divine and paternal might be
merely a reflection of that evolutionary process.
So that would be a biologically reductive argument for the existence of what we
experience as God.
But then there's another possibility too,
which is that that's actually reflective of a deeper metaphysical reality that
has to do with the nature of consciousness itself.
And I would say that I think that's true is I believe the biological case,
and I believe the biologically reductive case,
but I don't think that exhausted.
I think that there's a metaphysical layer underneath that,
that the bylaws,
that the biology is a genuine reflection of,
and that's the sort of the macrocosm above in the microcosm below that we,
that we are really reflective,
including in our consciousness of something about the structure of reality
itself.
And that might involve whatever,
whatever it is that God is,
we'll see that.
That's why I think this is so interesting because what you're doing there,
especially at the end as you're,
you're giving it a little room to say,
I don't know.
Right.
But you have to.
Yeah.
But I think that that's what people don't want to grant,
you know,
this is fine.
Then God,
it's like,
well that's like,
it's,
to me that question is always like,
well,
what makes you so sure that you know that God exists?
Right?
It's like,
well,
I'm not sure.
I'm not willing to claim that certainty,
you know,
but well,
but I laid out target.
I know,
right?
Yeah.
So what do you think about when he takes it all the way to that end and then
there's that little space at the,
I mean,
again,
I don't think that that's severely problematic in terms of just general
religious thought.
I mean the general religious circling back thousands of years,
and this is why when you look at Aquinas is proofs of God.
When he comes to his he,
he says basically what you say,
which is if you go down deep enough,
then you get to something and that something is what we call God.
So he doesn't say,
God,
he doesn't.
The Bible starts from the premise God exists and he created the universe.
Aquinas starts from we have a universe,
what's has god is there.
And he says,
what?
When you go all the way down deep enough,
there has to be a force that lies behind the combined logic of the universe.
And that thing is what we call God.
Right?
And so he's trying to reason his way back to first principles.
And I think that the,
the case for God,
not in the way that we think of him as like a jolly bearded guy in the sky who
like takes care of all of our problems or anything,
but the idea that there is a logos,
right?
This is,
there's a structure,
a fundamental structure to the way life is and that there was a reason and the
fundamental purpose to why life is and what lies below that you can call God and
that without,
without some association with it well and that well your consciousness reflects
God.
Again,
this is the,
this is one of the fundamental,
this is sort of light and it says proof of God.
Is that the principle of sufficient reason,
the idea that you are capable of understanding the universe if you actually
believe you're capable of understanding the universe in any way.
In any way,
then your mind has to in some if you believe in objective reality as Sam does
and you believe that your mind is capable of grasping and objective reality,
not evolutionarily beneficial reality,
but an objective reality,
your mind is reflecting a greater mind,
right?
Your mind is reflecting a greater logic.
Well what stands behind that greater logic?
It must be something,
right?
And so this is the idea that there is a guy that stands behind that.
So the proof for God I think honestly is,
is not supremely difficult.
And I think that we all do have,
whether it's biologically sourced or in my view logically sourced a belief that
there is a structure to the universe of predictable structure to the universe
that didn't emerge out of simple randomness and there is a reason that things
are the way that they are.
And that from that we can draw the fact that we are capable of acting within
that logical universe of everything were sheer chaos.
You could not act,
you'd be paralyzed by the caseloads around you.
So would you both argue them that at a micro level and at the individual level,
you could live a perfectly good,
decent life with whatever moral subset you create your thoughts with that.
But I think ultimately you're both making the argument that at a macro level of
society just can't,
can't function without
the mythos.
No,
you're embedded in that.
And so,
well,
and I was talking about this Christian idea too.
So,
so I've been thinking about that statement about um,
no one comes to the father except through me and thought,
okay,
well what does that mean exactly?
And I've worked a lot,
a lot of this out over these lectures that you know,
that you and I have been participating in.
Well,
so there is this notion and that that height and Luke and offer also pursuing
in,
in the coddling of the American mind that,
you know,
one of the ways that you in noble people and encourage them is by having them
confront things that are,
um,
frightening to them that are beyond them.
So what do you,
what you really want to do is you want to optimally challenge people.
And what that does is make them braver and stronger,
not less afraid.
It makes them more courageous and more competent.
Okay.
And I would say the clinical evidence for that is overwhelming.
If you,
if you pull a hundred educated clinicians and use,
and you say to them,
well,
is there utility in having people get their ethical story straight and face the
things that they're avoiding?
They're all going to say yes,
those are fundamental fundamentally curative.
And this is quite literally what we're doing.
The reverse side of that college.
Yes,
exactly.
It's quite literally the reverse of that.
Okay,
so now here,
here's the idea.
Here's the idea.
So imagine that you are in some sense the embodiment of that paternal spirit
that has characterized mankind since the dawn of time.
It's locked in you,
it's part of your potential.
And maybe that's coated,
that's coded at least in part biologically,
but it's also caught coated sociologically.
It's,
it's in the air,
so to speak,
around you in,
in the Ms. Olsen,
in the stories we tell each other.
Okay.
So now what you decide to do,
and this is,
this is where I think we could have an interesting conversation about the
relationship between Judaism,
Christianity.
So there's an idea in Christianity,
which is I think the central idea,
which is that you need to face the potential for malevolence that exists within
you and in the world.
So that's Christ confrontation with the devil in the desert with Satan in the
desert.
You have to come to terms with that malevolence that's part of the existence.
And you have to voluntarily accept the burden of suffering.
And so that's the acceptance of the cross.
Okay?
So you take on that,
you say the suffering.
So there's an idea that Christ is a messianic figure because he took the
suffering of the world onto himself.
And what that means to me is that he was someone speaking,
um,
conceptually who decided that the suffering of the world,
his responsibility,
and that that's what you're supposed to do.
You're supposed to decide that that's your responsibility.
You take that on bar as a burden.
You do the same with the malevolence.
So when you read history,
you read history as a perpetrator,
right?
Maybe you also read it as a victim,
but you certainly read it as a perpetrator and then that's on you.
Okay,
so then the question is what happens when you do that?
And I would say the answer is two things,
is that first of all,
it starts to force you to develop,
like to learn what you need to learn in the world and to absorb the information
that would enable you to start to face the suffering and to rectify it.
So that forces you to become a more competent person.
And that's the socialization part that you thought of is so important.
But then there's a secondary thing that happens too,
which is that taking on that additional stress and demand voluntarily transforms
you buy a logically,
because within your genetic structure,
let's say there's all sorts of potential,
but that won't be unlocked and lasts.
You place yourself in a position where the demands necessitated.
And so by following that pathway,
truth,
let's say the acceptance of suffering and the confrontation with malevolence,
so that's the heaviest load that you could take on.
Then you actually produce a psychophysiological slash spiritual transformation
in yourself that matures you into like the representation of the father on
earth.
That's why that,
that's how that
lays itself.
So I'm glad.
I'm glad he got us here because the question that I sent you,
I,
there was only one thing I said,
do you guys know when we started that I wanted to get to something about most of
the lectures that you are when we're doing these things,
you're usually talking about the old testament now,
obviously you're an old testament guy.
Couldn't find my,
my question was do you think that Ben or or just people that believe in the old
testament exclusively are missing something?
So you just laid out a case of something that potentially is missing there.
Do you use them that is aimed at fair oaks?
Well,
what I'm going to argue is that what you just said is fundamentally Unchristian
in the sense that you're saying that everyone is supposed to imitate Jesus.
And the basic conceit of,
from what I understand,
uh,
speaking with Christian theologians,
is that we are fundamentally and capable of taking on our own sin.
And so we have to have somebody who comes in the form of Christ on earth in
order to accept that suffering for us.
And that that is the purpose of God actually embodying himself in Christ is to
provide human beings the capacity to withdraw from original sin.
That we don't actually have the capacity beyond a certain point to overcome.
And that's why Jesus as a singular figure is necessary.
I actually agree from a Judaic point of view with everything that you say,
because for me it's about accepting the responsibility for my own sins on
myself.
And I don't have the ability to say that there is the,
the suffering servant,
the suffering lamb of God who sacrificed himself to relieve me of my sins and
therefore gives me a fair shot at life.
Yeah,
we'll see.
We'll cute.
That's a,
that's a really good objection I think.
And I think that there's a fair bit of confusion about that in the Christian
community,
for example.
So I would say that perspective is more explicitly Protestant and then then I
would put the Catholics next to that,
but then I would put the orthodox types fairly far away from that,
which is why so many Orthodox Christians I think have been interested in what
I'm saying because their sense,
and this is where my knowledge of Christian theology starts to run out because
if like I'm not an expert on,
you know,
in the,
in the doctrinal differences,
right.
Um,
their sense is that it's the invitation that's of primary importance.
Now it's,
it's a weird thing because even in classical Christianity you have let,
let's say,
Protestant Christianity,
you have this idea that,
well,
Christ died to save us all from our sins.
And so we're already redeemed.
But that doesn't alleviate the moral burden weirdly enough because you'd think
it should.
So there's this paradox,
and I think it's,
I think part of the reason for that,
this is,
this is an extraordinarily complicated thing,
but in the brothers,
Karamazov Christ comes back to Earth,
right?
And,
um,
in Seville,
during the Spanish inquisition,
and so he's doing his miracles and raising people from the dad and like being
all my messianic,
and first thing that happens is the inquisitor rests,
right?
Throws him in prison,
and then comes to visit them and basically says,
look,
um,
the last thing we need after setting up this church for 2000 years is you,
you're a lot of trouble.
You've put a moral burden on human beings,
that's too much for them to bear.
And so what we've done is watered it down and put some intermediaries in place
so that the moral demand that your example required doesn't just crush people
into nothingness,
right?
So every ideals a judge,
So then you have the ultimate ideal.
That's the ultimate judge.
And from the inquisitor's point of view,
that judge was too much.
It was too demanding.
And so I think there's an,
and so,
so anyways,
so the inquisitor goes through all this argument says we're going to have to,
you know,
get rid of you again because you're just too much to bear.
And so Christ lessons and doesn't says any,
doesn't say anything.
And then just when the inquisitor stands to leave,
Christ kisses him on the lips and the inquisitive turns white in shock and then
leaves.
But he leaves the door open.
And that's the brilliant,
that's a brilliant ending of,
of Dostoyevsky's pacesetter yeah.
Yeah.
What makes him such a genius?
Because he basically says something like,
well,
look,
the,
the Catholic Church did reduce the burden and it is corrupt in the way that
earthly organizations are likely to be corrupt.
And it does allow an out,
which is why you can put your sins on Christ,
let's say in that alleviates your moral burden.
But it still keeps the damn door open.
Well,
the tabs,
so this is why I think it's really fascinating having,
having spent a lot of time with Christian theologians in the past couple of
years writing this book.
Is that the original conceit?
I think when,
when,
when you talk with people who are Christian and Jewish and you have sort of
interfaith conversations,
uh,
the original one sentence can see the difference between them is that will
you'll hear from Jews is Judaism's acts based in Christianity is faith based.
G Christianity's about the acceptance of Christ.
When you accept Christ,
then you've accepted,
you need to accept and everything flows they're from.
And Judaism says it's not just about accepting God,
it's all these myths vote right there.
All these commandments that you have to do and these are what perfect you as a
human being.
It's,
it's the performance of these commandments accepting God's sovereignty because
he's the one who gave the commandments,
but you actually have to act in the world.
And if you don't act in the world,
then you haven't fulfilled your responsibility in the world.
And it could also be an argument where you could have,
although I know you wouldn't be thrilled per say,
you could have Jewish atheist in that they believe that it's just their actions
here.
Yes,
100% certain.
So this is why,
you know,
Jews have had VR,
and I think most Christians believe this too.
The idea of having a moral atheist is not really a difficult idea.
It's the idea of having a system built on atheism that's completely immoral and
will fall apart almost immediately.
And the idea of having a moral system builds on atheism.
If you examine your atheism closely enough,
I think falls apart.
I think that moral atheism is basically you separating your morality from your
atheism and then ignoring your atheism in pursuit of the morality,
which is what you can live fine that way,
that's fine.
But I don't think that that's psychologically sustainable.
Um,
if you actually examine the core of your ideas.
But with that said,
I think that Christianity after its original millenarian viewpoint,
when,
when Christianity first came about the idea of Christ on earth was that he had
ushered in the Messianic era because this was,
it was,
it was a new era.
It was a new day.
And then it turns out that people have around,
they went,
well,
this looks a lot like the old day.
Right?
And I'm not that much has changed.
And so what changed?
What changed was our spiritual status.
That was the new redefinition of the Messianic era is that the,
the what Christ had brought to earth was a new spirit right here.
He brought a new spirit into the earth and he cleansed people of their sins and
giving them a fresh shot at life basically.
Uh,
and that in doing so,
he changed the nature of,
of how things work.
Well,
Judaism basically said,
well,
we never thought that that nature change in the first place.
Right?
That's,
that's,
that's something different.
And so,
ironically enough,
I think one of the sources of Christian antisemitism over time is an attempt to
distinguish what makes Christianity different from Judaism other than Christ.
Because Christianity and Judaism in most of their main philosophies have an
awful lot in common.
It's interesting.
I just interviewed,
um,
a,
uh,
a fellow named John Macarthur,
who's a major pastor,
major Christian theologian.
I interviewed him a couple of days ago for our Sunday special and this came up.
I asked him,
so where do you think the differences are between Christianity and Judaism?
And he basically said,
Jesus,
right?
That's the difference.
And I think that that is the mostly honest answer because when I hear Christian
theologians tried to distinguish Judaism from Christianity,
what they say about Judaism,
I find to be not accurate as to what Judaism actually says.
And when I hear Jews tried to distinguish Christianity from Judaism,
I think that,
and I'm not saying they're the same thing because they're not,
obviously they're different belief systems,
but in terms of the underlying value system,
the reason that we say Judeo Christian value system is because in terms of the
value system itself,
the commonalities are overwhelming.
They're overwhelming.
The differences are mostly doctrinal and historical.
And in terms of what you think God,
I think the Christians read back in and ask based version of their own lives
through a variety of mechanisms.
Whether they say,
well,
predestination exists,
but in order to show that if I really elect,
I would be acting this way,
right?
That is an ax based version.
It's just retroactive from the end.
And so this is why if you say to a Christian,
so you really believe that you can lead a terribly dissolute awful,
terrible life.
But if you believe in Christ with the full fiber of your being,
you're going to heaven.
And they'll say,
and many of them will say yes,
but then you say,
but what makes a good person?
And they'll say right now,
but what they will always add.
But if you believe in Christ,
you wouldn't do all of those things.
Well that's,
that's the thing.
Well not,
and that's why people are always criticizing me.
When I give an answer to the question that you just asked because my,
my answer has been,
well,
I act as if God exists.
Well that's kind of weaselly.
It's like,
no,
it's not because it gets to the,
to the core of this.
What do you mean by belief?
Well,
do you believe in Christ?
does that mean you utter the words that he existed?
Well,
that's a pretty shallow form of belief.
In fact,
I think that's no form of belief at all.
it says in the New Testament,
Christ himself says something along the lines of not all those who uttered the
words,
Lord,
will be saved.
Right?
And so,
and niches,
criticism of Christianity,
doctrinal Christianity was basically based on the idea that Christianity had
taken the easy route out by insisting upon the statement of faith rather than
the embodiment of the belief in action,
which would be the imitation of Christ.
Which by the way,
is Jesus' original criticism of Judaism.
Right?
Is that everybody takes the the commandments extraordinarily seriously,
but they don't take the spirit of the commandments.
Yes,
exactly.
That's right.
That's exactly right.
It is the same.
It's the same thing.
And so you know,
niches,
criticism of Christianity was that there were very few real Christians because
they didn't take on the burden of the action.
And I would say it's the belief has actually manifested in the burden of the
action.
Now,
you might want to say,
you might want to be in a position if you are Christian,
to say,
well,
my explicit statements of belief match what I act out,
because maybe there'd be a unity in that.
But the fundamental issue is what you is,
what the belief is manifested in what you do,
because that's what you state for me.
Belief is what you stake your life on.
That's belief and you stake your life on what you act out.
And so you're trying to act out the idea that while that you take,
I think that you take on the suffering of the world and the malevolence of the
world as your responsibility.
You know,
and let's really fascinating,
and I think that what this comes down to,
a lot of this debate comes down to which from which end you're teaching.
I think that it's almost two sides of one coin.
And if you're talking to a bunch of people who are not religious,
you don't believe in the Bible,
right?
You're talking to an adult who looks at the Bible.
It says,
I don't believe all of these ridiculous miracles happen.
Why should I bother engaging?
Why,
why should I believe all this stuff?
And my argument has always been because you do believe all this stuff,
you're just pretending that you don't in the sense that you don't care about the
historical circumstance,
but all the things that you're acting out in daily life.
I sent this to Sam right on stage,
uh,
is,
is that,
you know,
you and I hold 95% same valleys.
Where do you think those came from?
And Sam said,
well,
you know,
I've done a lot of studying,
a lot of videos said,
but that doesn't explain why you and I hold 95% of the same values
because I haven't done any of those things.
Right.
I didn't spend any time studying the,
the philosophies of the east,
the reason we hold 95% the same values because you grew up in a Judaeo Christian
civilization with 3000 years of common history.
That's why we share the same value system.
Most rooms on a,
on a river in Brazil.
Exactly.
And,
and somehow we end up in pretty much the same place about what we think is
actually important in life,
in which liberties are important in all this stuff.
And we have disagreements around the edges.
But this is the west,
right?
This is,
the West is different.
It is not the same as other philosophies.
And so when I'm talking to people about that,
the case that I'm making is you are part of this great river of history.
You can pretend you're not part of that great river.
You can pretend you're not living off the fumes of that river you are living.
You can pretend that the gas tank is running on its own.
It ain't okay you,
there's a,
there's a deposit of fuel and you are still living off that.
That's but,
but that is a different thing than what you see to child.
And this is where I think that that things become different because I think that
your philosophy,
Jordan,
is self-sustaining to a group of people who are looking at re at the values they
live and saying,
where did these come from and how do I justify these values?
But I think that it'd be very difficult to teach child values before you teach
the math.
So I think that you're coming at people and saying to them,
your values can be justified by the myth.
Yeah.
But when you're teaching a child values,
it's a myth you have to teach.
You don't have to keep teaching the kids the story first of course,
and then come the values.
And so the,
and so there's a difference between,
and this is why even listen,
unless you teach the storage.
Firstly,
and this is why as a religious person,
I teach my kids the stories first because the values are embedded in the stories
and what I do.
I have questions about stories.
What rational person wouldn't have questions about the stories.
Of course you have questions about the reality or the historicity of the stories
that doesn't undercut,
number one,
the importance of the stories.
And number two,
the point is that you have to believe the fundamental assumptions embedded in
the stories,
whether or a in order for the values to in order [inaudible].
That's exactly why you said before that the enlightenment couldn't have just
sprung out of nothing.
Right?
I mean that's,
that's exactly what you were saying that it needed all of the bedrock would
think that for people who are fundamental evolutionary biologists,
and I kept trying to make this case to,
while you can make a case like that to pinker in the psychologist,
but also the Harris,
it's like what do you get?
Where do you guys get off thinking that this is a consequence of the last 300
400 years?
Right?
It's like we're,
we're looking at time spans.
Even the enlightenment figures,
they lived in a world that was like 6,000 years old.
We're living in a world,
there's three and a half billion years old.
You have to extend your thinking about the origins of phenomena,
like like morality,
way past,
way back past the enlightenment.
And so this adventure thing,
this is a good example of,
of the wisdom that's embedded in those myths.
So I didn't know that.
I will say sorry to just pause for a second.
And I would say in that history specifically because as a point of belief,
I do believe that this is a historical circumstance.
Uh,
and whether you call it myth or history,
as long as you believe the reality of myth and you and I believe in reality in
different ways and this is part of the fundamental distinction because my
understanding is that your understanding of what is true and what is real is an
almost
a quasi utilitarian channels purse view of it because you recommended me to
books,
but my view is much more like Samson,
the sense that most religious people believe the objective truth about
historical myth,
but when it comes to getting beyond that question,
then I think we're almost completed agreement.
The strange thing is too with these mythological stories is that like there are
forms of abstraction that are more true than then what they're abstracted from.
Right.
My mathematics is like that and I'm going to do a bunch of lectures on exodus
and I think the mosaic story is a really interesting example of that is like
what a good piece of here's a kind of truth.
This is literary truth.
And it's true is that while this happened,
then this happened and this happened and this happened and there was a pattern
about what happened.
And let's call that the heroic pattern,
for lack of a better word.
And so the question is,
well,
what's the reality?
Is the reality of the specifics of what happened in each person's individual
life or is it the general pattern that manifested itself across all those
people?
And I would say if you want to extract out guidelines for proper living than the
reality is the abstraction that's that's,
that's pulled out of the multiple stories.
And so even if the story of Moses is a composite story,
in some sense,
that doesn't mean it's not true.
It's true the way,
and this is something that I could never make headway with,
with regards to Sam.
It's like,
well,
is there literary truth?
Well,
there better be because otherwise,
what is the use of literature and how do you rank order literature in terms of
quality,
if there's no standard of truth?
Well,
what's the truth?
While it's an abstraction.
And if you don't think that abstractions are true,
then you're not thinking because you can easily make a case that a proper
abstraction is more real than the thing from which it's abstracted.
You certainly make that case with mathematics.
And so these stories,
it's not only that they have pragmatic utility,
although I tried to explain things biologically when I can do that,
it's that that utility is true in the broader sense,
that we've been describing truth.
And so this,
the Abrahamic story with the call to adventure is very interesting.
So,
um,
and it's something else that I've been lecturing to my audiences about.
It's,
well,
what's the purpose of life?
What's an adventure?
Well,
where do you see that?
you see that in the Abrahamic story in particular because Abraham's,
this guy who's fit,
who fails to launch,
right?
He's 80 and he's still in his father's Tanton.
God says,
you don't get that.
Yeah.
Well,
and that's the call,
right?
What is that you think?
Well,
there's a call to adventure while there is a call to adventure.
Young Men die without that call to adventure.
That's what attracts them to Isis for God's sake,
is the call to adventure,
right?
And you can say,
well,
that's warped and twisted in those individuals because the society hasn't cat
catalyze that into the proper channels,
right?
It hasn't given them a moral equivalent to war in William James terms,
it hasn't called them out properly,
but God calls out Abraham.
And all that happens to Abraham to begin with is that he encounters a famine and
a tyranny and a conspiracy to steal his wife.
Like it's a bloody catastrophe.
And you think,
oh,
I see.
Well,
it isn't that God is calling you out to happiness.
He's calling you out to the great adventure of your life.
Right?
And that comes along with the suffering and the burden and the malevolence and
all of that.
And so it's something grand and noble,
like a,
like a seafaring expedition on the high seas.
It's not,
it's not
that impulsive,
self-gratifying immediate happiness that seems to be,
what would you say,
the obsession of our current culture.
So I'm ready to call too.
It's called the physical adventure that I think people are lacking right now.
But I think it's also called the spiritual adventure in the sense that you are
supposed to see how your values stack up against reality.
I mean this is the most famous story of Abraham and said,
well,
the most famous story is the,
is the sacrifice of Isaac.
And in that story,
my view of that story is that I've never found that story particularly puzzling.
A lot of people find that story particularly puzzling because it's God's saying,
you know,
go sacrifice your son.
But to me what he's actually saying is the fundamental truth.
That story is the fundamental truth of raising a child and committing to
something.
Because what God is actually saying to Abraham is you have to put your child at
risk of death to live for a certain set of values.
And then Abraham has another say,
has enough faith to say,
and I trust that God is not actually going to kill my child.
But by committing to the set of values,
I am in fact putting my child at risk of putting your child in the world.
And yes,
that's right.
And not only that you're doing so on behalf of your family,
you're doing so on behalf of,
of the,
of your God you're doing so on behalf of a,
of a broader purpose.
And by the way,
this is what it means to be,
I think an emissary,
a fighter,
and a soldier and an emissary for the west.
I think this is true particularly,
you know,
as a Jew,
I think there's always been true of Jews.
Because here's the reality.
Every time I see some,
my son is born,
eight days later we circumcise him,
we take a baby and we pre commit him and we say,
this is going to be your life.
Now your life is,
I am pre committing you.
This is me doing,
you know what Abraham did?
Isaac,
I am putting my child in more danger by circumcising him and making him a Jew
than I would otherwise be because Jews are a lot more danger in the,
in the world than other people.
And,
and,
but that's the point is that I'm saying to my child,
I pre commit you to this struggle.
I pre commit you to the set of values and that does put you at additional risk,
but that's also what gives you meaning and throughout your history,
sometimes God doesn't find the ram in the thicket.
Right?
Sometimes there is no ram in the thicket.
Sometimes the kids die.
Right?
Okay.
That is it.
That is the reality of life and it's also the reality of committing to any value
system worth committing to.
It's so interesting because I don't know that I've heard you talk about this in
the lectures,
the specific issue through the biblical Lens,
but this is so consistent with everything else you talk about,
about how to be a good parent,
that you've got to let them.
Well you see danger all you,
when you were,
when you were talking about that,
the image that came to my mind was Michelangelo's Pieta because what happens
with Mary is that she has foreknowledge that her son will be broken by the
world.
And yet she offers,
she offers him up to the world.
And then you think,
well if,
if a parent doing this in a moral manner,
then you are offering up your children to be broken by the world in the service
of God.
That's a sacrifice to God.
And if you're the proper parent than you do sacrifice,
you do sacrifice your children to God because what you want from them for them
is to serve the highest possible value.
If you love them,
that's what you want.
And,
and that's a mortal burden for them.
And while that's perfect,
perfectly illustrate it,
cause I think that have the,
that is the sort of the female equivalent of the crucifixion,
right?
Because of course Mary is his integrity bound up with her son and yet,
and he's broken sort of at the peak of his power and beauty,
all of that.
And she has to accept that as part of the precondition of property existence.
And so there's a real sacrificial element there and that is reflected in that
story and so and and,
and it's,
and it's correct in that manner and it's a very rough story.
So that teaching your children values is in effect sacrificing to the worlds in
a way that they wouldn't if you are teaching them the values.
But it's also what allows them to live a fulfilling life in doing that in pre
committing your child's values.
This is one of the major problems that I have with the way that the left has,
has rewritten parenting is idea of parenting is that you're just supposed to let
your kid rush out into the world of that.
Any preparation at all without any pre committed set of values and discover the
world on their own without anything.
That's one thing to say you should encounter danger.
It's another thing to make everything inherently more dangerous by not preparing
your child for the possibility of a world that requires values and meaning.
Oh by the way,
we saw this at hand in Sweden where we were,
we weren't sure why there was so much support for everything you're doing in
Sweden.
And when we do this Q and a after where people are submitting questions,
you know,
online.
And then I look through them as Jordan's doing his talk and then we answer
questions.
And 90% of the questions had to do with gender issues and a ton of them were
about genderless kindergartens and the emasculation of the father and all of
this stuff.
And it's like,
that's exactly what you're saying.
You've given these kids well.
It's also,
well,
it's also extremely interesting following up on your line of reasoning that,
well let's say you do decide,
well I'm going to launch my children out into the world to let them discover
everything by themselves.
Well,
so what happens is while the world becomes so terrifying that you have to
protect them from everything because they don't have any,
they don't have any autonomy.
They don't have no,
exactly.
They don't have any discipline.
They don't have any inbuilt values,
all of that.
And so the,
the counter consequence of that maximum freedom,
and I've seen this with people,
they have two year old kids and they've put no restraints on them whatsoever.
They haven't taught the kid what no means.
Like can,
you can teach a kid what no means very rapidly.
So if you have a child that's learning to crawl,
for example,
and you know,
maybe they're going to go pull something heavy off the shelf,
all you have to do is grab them by the leg and hold them and say no over and
over until they stop doing what they're doing.
And they'll usually cry.
And so,
you know,
that's cruel.
Okay.
So you stopped them.
And then if you do that for a week,
then all you have to say no,
and they'll cry and stop and then two weeks later they won't cry.
They'll just stop.
Now knows a big deal.
Right?
Because no is the imposition
of the patriarchy against that,
against that instinctive explore.
Noble savage.
Yeah,
that's right.
Against the noble savage.
Right.
So it's a big deal.
No.
So,
but then,
okay,
but then now once your child has got that you can leave them be cause they can
explore like mad yet first of all you can stop them by saying no and so that's
really helpful because if they're going to do something dangerous award we'll do
it.
But second kids are really smart and what I learned with my kids was once you
taught them that there were five things in the house they couldn't do,
then they generalize from that and they figured out the pattern of the things
they couldn't do and then they wouldn't do them.
And then you could leave them alone.
They could be autonomous and then parents would come over who didn't teach their
kids know and they would follow their two year old around like totalitarian is
100% of the time because they couldn't trust them to have any autonomy at all.
Yup.
So the consequence of that absolute lack of discipline is the necessity for
constant supervision.
And this is,
it's also one of the reasons why I have so much trouble with the way that he's
speaking of the genderless parenting aspect is one of the reasons I have so much
trouble with all of this,
this idea that kids,
that everything is biologically prewritten and biologically determined and that
how you raise your children has no impact on how their future life goes is such
asinine bullshit.
I mean,
sorry to put it that way,
but it just is,
I have two kids under five.
It is absolute nonsense.
So I told the story the other day on the radio or on my show on podcast about my
son.
So my son is two and a half years old and he has just a delightful human being,
which means that if you are an adult,
he'd be the worst person because he has two year olds are savages.
This is what they are.
Uh,
anybody who tells you that children are naturally good is totally full of it.
Children are naturally innocent.
Children are naturally not good.
Children are naturally selfish and mean and brutal to each other.
And then they're joyous.
And then their home joy right there.
This is what they are.
And so my son was,
he has an older sister and his older sister love sparkly things.
It's just her thing.
She's a,
she's a girl,
right?
And she's very girly and so she has all of these sparkly shoes laying around.
And so my son decided that he wanted to go and put on his history sparkly shoes.
And I went to him and I said,
no,
those,
those are girls' shoes.
Oh.
I said,
no,
those are girls' shoes.
We don't wear those.
And he said,
and he started to fuss.
He said,
no.
I want,
I want the,
I won't,
I won't say her name,
I want her shoes,
I want her shoes.
And I said,
those are girl things.
And then I took him to the out,
the western outfitters over here and then eyes and I got him a pair of cowboy
boots and he will not take off his cowboy boots.
Now the way the left would see that is that is me cruelly crushing his spirit.
Perhaps he just wants to be a girl.
Perhaps he wants to be raised in a feminine manner.
Yeah,
except that by me giving him the choice by going and getting them cowboy boots
and then saying,
here,
here's some cowboy boots and as more gender appropriate,
it turns out that that's what he likes and you know what?
Even if he didn't like that,
he's two and a half years old.
The year man,
I get to decide for him the amount of hate that I'm going to get just for
sitting here listening to you tell that story of how you parent and I didn't
push back on Shapiro son to wear sparkly shoes.
Robin,
he's not an adult when he's 17 if he makes eight an affirmative case,
why he should wear a sparkly shoes.
Yeah,
go for it.
Yeah.
When he's two and a half,
I'm the guy who gets to instill these system that I think will lead to his
greatest happiness.
I am the totalitarian in my own house.
I am the king of my own house and I get to determine whether I think my child
will live a happier life,
struggling with the desire to wear sparkly shoes at age 25 or whether it might
be better for him to be brought up in a situation where it's easier to choose in
line with gender stereotyping.
That by the way,
is reflected over every human culture.
The idea that gender stereotyping is unique to the West is absolute nonsense.
There are differentiations between how we treat men and how we treat women in
every culture in the history of humanity.
Yeah.
Well that again is why the Sweden thing was,
yeah.
Well,
I mean because we found out basically as,
as you laid out and feel free to clean this up.
Yep.
Was that they've done egalitarianism,
right.
Men and women have been equal for quite some time and yet still what has
happened there is that more men are engineers and more women are nurses.
Yeah.
And that men and women are more different.
There's still different and more new.
More.
Yeah,
that's right.
The social justice warriors or,
or whatever this thing is.
They won't let them have the win.
So they,
yeah.
Well you experiment.
Well the other,
the other issue here too is,
well imagine that just hypothetically imagine that you were going to try to
raise your children gender neutral.
Okay.
So there was actually studies done on this back 30 years ago where they looked
at self professed feminist parents and self professed on feminist president
parents and then coded their interactions blindly for a gender stereotypical
behavior and found no difference between the two groups.
Huh?
Well and the reason for that is,
you know,
you think that you socialize your children entirely.
If you're a social constructionist,
it's all top down,
right?
Because your child is a blank slate,
but your child isn't,
your child is manifesting to a greater or lesser degree,
all sorts of gendered behaviors and powerfully and a lot of what you're doing,
especially if you're a good parent,
is you're reacting to what your child is manifesting as an individual.
And so a lot of the socialization that show called the socialization,
which sounds like top down is actually the establishment of an of a singular
relationship between you as the parent and that individual child with their
nature and this is,
this is also reflected in the behavioral genetics literature because what you
see is that imagine there's three sources of variation in children's behavior.
There's biological,
there's shared environment,
so this would be the sibling,
so this would be what was the same in the family for the siblings and then what
was different and then you look at the behavioral outcome and you calculate how
much was biological,
how much was shared environment and how much was non shared environment.
What you find is it's almost all biology in non shared environment and so people
have read that to say while parents don't matter because there's no shared
environment,
but it's not the case because what happens is if you're a good parent is the
relationship you have with child one is significantly different than the
relationship that you have with child too.
Even though there may be moral presumptions that are organizing your families in
your,
truly,
your children identically are almost never right.
It's never to Cain and Abel,
right?
I mean,
but that's a,
that's right.
I mean like if God is the parent figure in that story,
treating your children's differentially is a way of being a good parent for your
kids.
Exactly the same.
You are not being responsive to your kids and you're teaching them that,
that essentially there are no consequences to actions because your kids taking
their luncheons,
right,
no matter what.
It's the same outcome.
Well,
that's just good parenting,
right?
No,
no,
no.
That's,
that's almost the definition of totalitarian parenting.
And it is exactly the kind of relationship that you don't want to have with
anyone,
right?
You want all of your relationships to be individualized in particular.
Rised and so and so.
Um,
so the,
so we,
we,
we radically underestimate the degree to which the gendered interactions between
children and parents are driven by the children.
So here's a funny experiment.
There's some evidence that parents who drink more are more likely to have
children with Adhd.
Now,
I'm not a big fan of ADHD diagnosis,
but we'll leave that aside.
Okay.
So,
so then there was some suggestion that may be,
well,
ADHD is part of a genetic complex that involves alcoholism and antisocial
personality cause those things also clumped together.
And so there's various experiments done to see if that is the case.
And there's a fair bit of diagnostic overlap between childhood conduct disorder
and Adhd.
So it's kind of messy,
irrelevant.
Here's the experiment.
You bring parents in to interact with children who aren't their own and you,
you have them do an alcohol taste test.
And so the taste test is,
well here's rum and coke and here's vodka and orange juice and here's the orange
juice and here's water.
And what we want you to do is to just rate the taste of each of these beverages.
Okay.
And so then we expose you to some children.
And one of the children is a child with a diagnosis of Adhd and one of the child
children is one that doesn't.
And then so you do that with a bunch of parents and then you have them do the
taste test.
Okay,
well you don't care what they rate the damage drinks,
you just care how much they drink.
And it turns out that parents that were exposed to the kids that have attention
deficit disorder drank far more so.
But that's a good,
it's a good example of the idea of Bi directionality and socialization.
It's like you're not,
you have a relationship with your child.
Now you obviously enforce a certain degree of social norm if you're sensible
because you want your child to be socialized and desirable to other people.
You want them to be able to play reciprocally and you want them to be attentive
enough to adults so that adults treat them well.
So the world opens up to them.
Right?
So that's what you're doing.
But other than that,
your particular Ising like mad because even to get that child to that end state
requires a particular eyes path.
You know,
my daughter was intrinsically very cooperative and my son was intrinsically very
competitive.
And so the pathway to getting them both to be reciprocal players was
substantially different even though the desired outcome.
And they became reciprocal players.
Like they,
you know,
they were pop,
they were popular kids who in constant demand as playmates,
which I think is the hallmark of successful parenting,
by the way,
by the time if your kids are four and other kids really want to play with them,
it's like you did it,
you got it right.
And if they're not,
then something's gone seriously wrong.
But there's multiple pathways to that.
So I'm glad we got this to the current day because one of the things that I
wanted to ask you guys about is what we're basically talking about here is
living life with a certain set of rules and we can whittle away
12,
12 of them,
although I hear there's going to be a couple more coming.
That's the rumor that had 10,
12,
whatever.
Um,
but we,
it seems to me,
we live in a time where,
where the energy is just around the people that have no rules.
So,
you know,
sort of as the Trump thing grew,
it was this sort of destructive force that break all the things.
Right.
And Eric and I talked about how Eric would have wanted,
Eric Weinstein would have wanted a panther in a China shop,
but I said,
you just don't get that.
You get the bull in the checkout.
That's how it is now.
I see the energy behind sorta the SJW left and the new s that socialism is cool
and let and that it's much easier to destroy than create.
Do you think that the rules that you lay out in your book and the rules that you
talk about from a biblical perspective and everything else that people with
rules can sort of survive in in a crazy time like we're in now where information
travels that much faster and there's that much sort of entropy behind chaos that
maybe there wasn't before because we couldn't transmit information so quickly?
Do you think there's enough enough
juice behind this basically disagree slightly with the premise of your question.
I don't actually think that the left doesn't have rules.
I think they have more rules than we do.
I think the,
that we have a certain basic set of rules and then an immense amounts of freedom
within these guard rails.
I think the left in getting rid of the guard rails head who because human beings
cannot live without rules,
the left [inaudible],
this is actually an important point.
They reversed engineered a set of extraordinarily complex rules that are
arbitrarily applied.
So you don't even know you violated rule until after you've tripped over the
rule.
Right?
Know if they replaced rules with taboos.
Right,
exactly,
exactly.
And that is extraordinarily dangerous so that the energy is behind seeking a new
set of rules.
The question is,
can we defend our rules in such a way that it is attractive to people?
Except I'll,
except I think you do that.
I think you do that fundamentally by pointing out the relationship between rules
and aspiration.
It's like the rules define a value hierarchy and then that gives you something
noble to do.
That's your call to adventure.
Exactly.
So the rules don't constrain.
They do constrained.
You obviously rose constraint,
but at the same time they constrain,
they provide an organizing framework and a direction and that's,
and you need,
and that,
that direction isn't optional because the other thing,
you know,
rules like pants.
Okay,
you put them on and they're fundamentally constraining,
but they lied to walk through brambles.
Right?
Well that's,
well,
that's also why when you see that,
one of the first things that happens in the garden of Eden,
when Adam and eve become self conscious as they put on clothes.
Exactly right.
It's a constraint and a protection at the same time.
And again,
culture is always that it's constrained in protection at the same time.
And the,
the radical types are always going,
oh,
you know,
the constraint or the constraint.
And Fair enough,
right?
Because there's that tyrannical aspect,
but the,
the protection and the aspiration are absolutely critical importance.
And I don't think there is a more,
I don't think that we've laid out anywhere a more noble orientation with regards
to disciplined aspiration then that that's encoded inside the Judaeo Christian
ethic and that that is the core of the enlightenment.
And that is right.
Okay.
So I had another question about Judaism.
Okay,
sure.
Okay.
So one of the things that I would then,
I've always wondered about is,
I think one of the things that distinguishes Christianity from Judaism is that
Judaism has an implicit emphasis on the salvation on the cell,
on the salvific properties of the state.
And I don't think you see that in Christianity to the same degree.
So I mean,
because there's,
well,
while there's not,
there's the idea of Israel's,
that's part of it.
And,
and there's the idea of the Jewish nation as a people,
right?
Whereas Christianity has this universalism that's built into it.
This is right.
And so,
and this,
this is a fundamental distinction.
Okay.
So,
okay,
so,
so on,
this is,
I've never been able to have this conversation with anyone because it's an
unbelievably dangerous conversation.
But it seems to me that,
it seems to me that the advantage of Christianity is that it places the
fundamental locale for salvation within the individual.
I mean,
independently of whether it's like pushed off for reasons of mercy onto Christ.
Something else we didn't finish discussing is one of Young's points with regards
to Christianity and Catholicism was that there was a merciful element to it
because the burden that was placed on each person being the locus of,
of redemption,
let's say,
was so heavy that it was unbearable and so that you needed an intermediary
structure to like lift the load off of you from time to time,
which is what the Catholics do.
It's like,
well,
here's all the ways that I've failed.
That's okay.
You're fallible.
You're a fallible human being.
You don't have to be crushed into absolute dust by the fact that you're not
everything you should be.
So all right,
but anyways,
I think that's where Jewish guilt kicks in if I'm not well,
and it's also I think to some degree where Protestant guilt kicks in because the
Catholics have that out.
And you can be cynical about that,
right?
Say,
well,
you sit in your whole life and then on your deathbed you're converted.
It's like,
well,
that's all nonsense because you actually have to repent.
And so if you have a lifetime of sin,
there's going to be a hell associate.
That's right.
But you can see the mercy in that,
in that,
in the Catholic approach,
because it gives you like a reset in some sense,
right?
You get to be washed.
The fact that you're not everything you could be is a terrible burden,
right?
And if you're carrying that all the time,
it can just crush you into nothingness that's present in its earlier iteration
in the,
in these sacrificial system in the temple among Jews,
uh,
or among the vending,
like I say,
in
three times a day,
you say a portion in the Montessori and the silent prayer,
uh,
in which you repent your sentence and then we have a full day.
Right?
You don't get bored.
It's deliberately designed to do that and to try and wipe the slate clean and be
a fresh start.
But as far as the,
the other question that you're asking about the individual,
right?
So to me it's less about the state per se,
because when we're talking about the nation of Israel,
Ami,
Sir Alan,
the in the actual biblical parlance,
it's not talking about like a border state and corporate salvation within that,
it's about the special responsibility of this group of people to,
to spread light to the world,
right?
That you're supposed to be in the,
again,
Hebrew phrase from you losing a lot of Hebrew today,
but we're talking bibles,
we'll be okay,
is that you're supposed to be on my MCAT Cohan and midway condos,
meaning that you're supposed to be a nation of priests and a holy nation.
Uh,
and so that idea was expanded by Christianity to all of Cuba,
all of humanity corporately that basically this,
this applies equally to all humans.
Now what's interesting about Judaism is the Judaism actually has almost a two
track approach.
So if you are a Jew,
then you have these responsibilities,
the 613 minutes vote,
you are not barred from the afterlife or from decency if you're not a Jew.
So Judaism is only half exclusive in the sense that if you're a junior Jew and
if you're not a Jew,
we try to actually dissuade you from becoming one.
But if you are a,
but if you are outside the Jewish nation,
you have a share in the afterlife as long as you fulfill seven basic
commandments,
the commandments of Noah,
right?
So there's a set of seven commandments that were given to Noah.
These are basic basic things.
Don't steal,
don't murder,
don't commit adultery,
don't eat the flesh of living animal a,
don't you have to create courts of justice.
Uh,
the,
these are like all very,
very basic loss.
And so what that means is that Judaism posits that you're on his own.
He has really interesting philosopher from Israel.
He has a new book out called the case for nationalism,
essentially.
Yeah.
It's really,
it's really interesting.
And basically the case that he makes is that the biblical Jewish view of where
values should be embedded at the maximum level is a safe review.
Then the universalistic conception because the universalists conception that you
have a set of values that applies equally to everyone across all times and
cultures actually leads to tyranny and cram downs.
Meaning that his argument is that the threat of the 20th century was not a bunch
of nationalism that we're embedding particular values.
It was certain nationalism that wanted to become universalisms.
It was Germany wanting to be the rife that ruled the entire world or the USSR
wanting to be a country that was able to apply communism across all times in all
places.
So a certain level of particular prism in how we apply basic rules.
The seven laws of Noah in the biblical case or the 10 Commandments,
you can have certain cultural differentiations and that allows for group
cohesion and in a way that you can't with them.
Great mass of humanity because how many tower of Babel problem,
right?
Things expand the,
if you expand the does exactly right to be too large,
then it starts to become too complex and they structure and to totalitarian
exactly it.
So the Jewish critique of,
of the universalistic principle would be,
yes,
there are certain fundamental universal principles that we should all hold buy
and those we hold a have to get by Jews and non Jews alike,
but how those are iterated,
they have to be iterated within a specific cultural structure.
Otherwise,
what you end up with is people trying to cram down cultural hallmarks of those
structures on everybody else and totalitarianism springs from the idea that I'm
going to take my culture,
which is different,
not actually better,
right?
Like we don't actually say that the 613 commandments are necessary for everyone
there.
They're not necessarily for people who are not Jewish,
and to take that and say,
okay,
now everyone has to abide by those things would be a form of totalitarianism in
a way that that is not,
when you say we have this particular set of values that is iterated to us in a
particular way.
Okay,
but maybe we could,
maybe we could think about it this way.
Maybe that would include both sides is that there is a danger to claims of
universalism and that's that large scale totalitarian utopianism.
And maybe you could,
you could criticize the universalism of Christianity as contributing to that
from a conceptual perspective,
but maybe you could say the same thing about the concentration on the
particular,
on the side of the,
of the Jewish emphasis on,
on the state,
and that because there are obviously pathologies of ethno nationalism and
localization that also manifest themselves as another kind of danger.
Right?
It would be the danger of too much exclusion and the danger of not enough
exclusion.
Right.
And so the issue is how you get the relationship between the individual and the
crap.
Correct.
Yeah.
Well,
this is one of the things that I think the EU is really struggling with is
because,
you know,
I'm kind of oddly enough for someone who's a universalist.
Let's say I'm somewhat,
I'm sympathetic to the claims of the nationalists in the European Union because
it seems to me that what they're complaining about is that as sovereign
individuals,
there have been levels of bureaucracy laid out in this huge overarching
structure,
the EU that divorce them as individuals from their masters.
Right.
And they want a local structure so that they have some relationship with the
structure.
Right.
And maybe you see in a place and localism,
by the way,
with other human beings,
I mean the fact is that you,
if you didn't value your own child more than you value the child of a stranger,
this would probably make you a bad person.
Right?
Right.
Like we would actually consider you a bad person.
Like if different,
definitely you had the choice between saving.
If I'd trust me and saving my son and saving a random kid of the same age,
and I said,
you know,
I don't see any difference between these two things,
right?
This would make me a bad person.
So the idea of having societal bonds that are local in nature is one of the
things that America got right in in some regional federal structure is the idea
of localism.
Localism is very important as opposed to one set of rules for everybody because
we do have these variations and those variations allow us to have the social
fabric that's necessary.
You can't tell.
This is actually where,
I mean to bring it full circle back to the online stuff.
The online world is a giant Savannah.
It is just one huge plane,
right?
There is no hierarchy in the online world,
and not only that,
there are no pockets in the online world on Twitter.
It's just one huge plane that doesn't generate any feeling of community.
What generates a feeling of community is people who you actually have social
ties with,
and those social ties are necessary.
Social fabric cannot exist for 6 billion or 7 billion human beings.
Social Fabric exist in your community.
Right.
And as large as that community can grow and there are limits to the growth of
that community.
And maybe this is what both Christianity and Judaism have in common when it
talks about the messianic era is there will be a time when that social fabric
can in fact encompass everybody.
But that's not something that happens naturally.
Might also still be that it's still full of particularities.
Exactly right.
It's just at the particular,
they just have to be,
have to be properly within a cone within a context.
Right.
We like the EU in the sense that they have a certain set of social values and as
the social values disappeared,
we'd like the EU less,
but those social values have to be in common.
Right.
So we all have to have those in common.
Yes.
The French don't want to be English.
The English don't want to be French and that's perfectly okay.
They don't have to be French.
Whoa.
It's kind of Nice that there are French and English like that.
That's part of the upside of diversity,
let's say,
is that there is some genuine diversity in that localism preserves that
diversity.
And this is what's so funny about the left,
right?
The left will say that diversity is our,
is our greatest benefit.
And then they immediately tried to wash away every thing that is diverse about
how people behave except for [inaudible].
Right.
Well that's no fun.
At the same time,
they'll also say,
well we should be more like countries like Sweden and Norway and Finland.
Some of them are quite dangerous countries on planet earth,
right?
I mean like,
yeah.
And by the way,
there were plenty of people there who are very worried about the directions that
their countries are going.
Oh,
sweet.
All these lefties in America thing.
Oh,
it's so great over there in the amount of people that we met there that are
completely
afraid of saying any,
the Sweden,
Sweden,
Norway and Denmark are immigration restrictionist countries.
It's so funny,
the left,
we'll talk about the wonders of Sweden is now,
right?
But because of the backlash,
Because of the backlash to massive Islamic immigration into Sweden and they,
and the fracturing of society in areas like Momo,
right is why all the Jews are leaving Sweden and Sweden has elected a central
rate government specifically on the immigration issue.
So yeah,
I mean to,
to ignore him for me individually and collectively.
Um,
the biggest source of unhappiness for people is pretending that reality isn't
reality.
When people fight reality,
they lose.
And recognizing that reality is reality is,
is necessarily whether you're a nation like Sweden or whether you are an
individual who's struggling with certain realities,
like people's unhappiness springs from thinking that reality is mutable but they
are immutable.
Mostly your immutable in reality is not mutable.
Yeah.
All right.
I got,
I got one more for you guys cause we,
you got about 10 minutes.
So let's go deep and personal with the theme that we've run with here.
I want to know a little bit about the adventure.
You are both non,
we've,
I've been on this adventure with you at least for the last couple of months.
Um,
but we,
I've asked you this before a couple of times and you always give me a slightly
different answer.
Where does it come from within you that you can do this?
And that's what I want to ask you too.
Like where does it come from that you,
you sure you can know all these things.
You can say all these things.
You can read about all these things with bet you Jordan Peterson can
get out there every day.
Put your ass on the line,
take all the hate,
keep going.
What is it about you?
Well,
the first thing that we should point out is that,
you know,
I have the same experience that Ben has in public.
It's like I've had one negative interaction in public and it was minor and it
was in Dublin with a woman who was really drunk [inaudible] and it wasn't even
that bad,
you know?
But,
but I've had thousands of personal interactions with people and they're all
unbelievably positive.
They're not just positive like there people approach me and they're very polite
and they're often apologetic because they think they're interrupting me.
And,
um,
you know,
then we have a brief personal conversation and they talk about how while they'd
been reading or listening or whatever and that their lives are up straightening
out and that that's really good and that they've recommended the book and,
and so I'm very happy about that.
And,
but it's just a hundred percent positive and so,
and that,
and it's an amazing and uplifting thing to be able to go all over the world.
Like I was in Slovenia a week ago.
I think the effect of Youtube,
by the way,
I think they effect of Youtube and podcasts is even bigger in places where the
media isn't as reliable or well developed as it is in the west.
It's hard to say how,
how huge a in effect it has,
but it's unbelievably big.
And so people were stopping me all over and,
and it's a remarkable thing to go into a new city and have complete strangers
approach you in the most positive possible way.
And then to tell you something private about their lives and then to share with
you some triumph they've had.
It's like that.
There's nothing that can be better than that.
And then when we do these lectures,
it's that on Mohs,
right?
We have like 1,002 thousand people come to the auditoriums.
And very little of what we've been discussing is being political,
except,
except the way we've been discussing politics.
You know,
the general level three [inaudible] is a variant of philosophical orientation
set,
but it's almost all centered on individual development.
And so it's,
it provides a kind of energy like in that,
and then I've been in the more and more fortunate position over the last nine
months because although I still find it very stressful to have contentious
interviews with journalists like the Gq interview for example,
um,
they have their advantages,
you know,
it's,
it's not like they're a net loss in terms of promoting what I'm trying to do,
which is try to help individuals fortify themselves.
And then so all of the elements of this that are positive is enough to sustain
this and,
and to enable it to continue and to also make me think that there isn't anything
more relevant or meaningful or adventurous that I could possibly be doing.
Feeding the meaning at the same time.
Cause that's an absolute through this is like every night that were out there,
there's this like renewed sense of,
wow,
this is real.
Not just putting it up and let it go to the university.
It's like we're seeing these people.
When that guy,
we almost took off late for one flight,
when that guy that was working at the airline came up to you right in the front
row and was going on and on and he could barely speak.
And it was like,
holy
people,
you know,
they say,
well,
my,
my girlfriend and I decided to get married.
Now we're having a baby because we've listened to your lectures.
Or here's here,
I'm here with my father.
And we put our relationship that happened,
the father and son who had,
who literally hadn't seen each other,
I think they said seven years.
Yep,
Yep.
And they were all smiling way and like,
it's just endless stories like that.
And I believe,
while I believe two things,
I believe that the individual is the fundamental locus locus of salvation and
redemption.
I truly believe that.
I don't think there's anything that's more true than that.
And then every time I see someone who's put themselves together,
I think that's one more major victory.
Not Minor.
You know,
which is also why I'm always talking to the individuals in the audience.
And when we do these meet and greets afterwards,
which kind of have this commercial cheesiness about them,
you know,
but,
but I don't care about that because that's how it's,
that's how it has to be.
That's how it has to be.
It says,
and it's set up so that it works.
I meet 150 people and I'm very careful with every single person that I interact
with.
And the reason for that is because I'm absolutely thrilled that they're,
they're,
you know,
they're there,
they're there because they are trying to not make things worse minimally.
Right.
And so,
you know,
one of the themes that we've been discussing in these lectures continually is
that not only do you have a moral obligation to aim up and be good,
like to pick the highest value that you can conceive of and pursue that
honestly,
but that if you don't do that to the degree that you fail,
something that's hellish takes that space.
And I really believe that.
Like I believe that since 1987 when I was studying totalitarianism,
I realized that it was the abdication of individual responsibility in the final
analysis that led to the horrors of Nazi Germany and the totalitarian Communist
states.
It was on us,
each of us.
And so I thought,
well then the thing to do about that is to do whatever you can to strengthen
individuals and to make them more,
more like appropriate moral agents.
Not Rights,
not the individual rights,
but the individual responsibility.
And I,
I truly believe that that's how you keep hell at bay.
And so there's a look,
cause I really believe that there's a lot of energy in that.
It's like I'm not interested in having a replication of what happened in the
20th century,
like enough of that enough.
And so if,
if with each person that's on a better path that that probability decreases by
one 7 billion,
then so be it.
And I think the effect is much larger than that because I think it's a network
effect.
I
don't think,
I mean this is what I was saying to you right before we started,
I don't think we can really understand how big it is because now there's
lectures,
you're doing your show live,
I'm doing standup Rogan's doing his thing,
Sam's doing all these things and it's not just about us.
I don't want to make it just about us,
but that there is some other energy.
So when I talk about the energy of destruction
that's out there,
I think there is a great energy creation and I think we're part of it.
I don't know how you're going to top that answer.
I'm just going to a short form,
which is I,
it's,
it's fascinating.
So I go out in public as I say,
and a lot of people want to take pictures and I'm sure Jordan gets it as much or
more night.
Uh,
and when you do that,
it's you always hear from people.
Yeah,
you know,
I met this celebrity on the street and they were just such a jerk,
right?
Like a women,
an actor.
And the actor was like miffed that they had to get up from dinner.
I have never felt the experience where somebody wanted to take a picture and I
was not delighted that they wanted to take a picture.
And I think the reason for that is not because like old look at me,
I get to be in this random person's picture that he puts on as well.
But because if you actually believe that what you're doing is a reflection of
values that matter,
it's not that they're engaging with me,
right?
So they're engaging with the ideas that I am,
that I am stating.
And that's unbelievably exciting that I made in my entire life to espousing a
certain set of values.
And now millions of people are engaging with those values.
And finding those values meaningful.
This is why I,
it's hard for all of us not to sound arrogant because we take our values so
seriously.
So when we say that maybe the hope for the country lies in the fact that there
are so many people who actually watch stuff like this.
I don't mean that because I care if people,
if people were watching me face paint,
you know,
then I don't think that that would have any meaning for me.
But the fact that people watch my show and that they're getting some semblance
of truth and values out of it.
And what's it,
I will say it is weirder for me.
I think it's probably better for me than it is for you Jordan,
because you talk so much about self help and about individual help and all this
kind of stuff.
Because I'm a plot a politics guy and I spend most of my day breaking down
current events.
The fact that I get so many people who email me and I send them to my wife,
I send them to my,
my parents cause I,
this is the stuff I'm actually the proudest of is when I get emails from people
and I got one today from some guy who said,
yeah,
I knocked at my girlfriend and I didn't know what to do about it.
And then I started listening to your show and I realized that for me to be a
better and more responsible human being,
I needed to marry my girlfriend.
And we've been married now for three years and my,
she was thinking about getting an abortion.
I listened to your show,
she didn't get an abortion.
Now we have a kid and it's just an amazing,
amazing thing.
Like that's the stuff that I care about.
I think politics,
what I do for living the politics,
that's the stuff that's existing on top of the iceberg.
And what I hope I'm doing is talking about this in a sense that allows people to
draw a straight line down to the bottom of the iceberg and said,
okay,
well the real important stuff is not what's happened in the Mueller
investigation up here.
It's what's happening in terms of truth and decency and waiting for available
evidence down here to take one example.
And so every news story is supposed to tie down into the rootedness of a value
system and the fact that people are hungry for those values.
That is what I'm really excited about.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's absolutely,
well,
you know,
I mentioned earlier that the tendency of the audiences to go silent when I talk
about the relationship between meaning and responsibility,
and that's,
well that's a sustaining thing.
It's like,
look,
there's all these thousands of people and what are they starving for our heavy
moral burden.
This is right.
So amazing.
It's like,
hey,
money opinion,
sometimes 150 bucks a ticket,
one of the best look,
I hear someone say,
fix yourself and buy my shit.
Don't,
I'm not anything,
you know,
there's a book,
but yeah,
but it's like,
it's on you.
It's on you bolt on you.
This is,
this is the reality of the backlash because for thousands of years it was the
religious community saying you have responsibility,
you have duty,
you have responsibility of duty.
And then over the last hundred and 50 years,
people like,
no,
we're not gonna do any of that stuff.
You know what,
forget it.
And now people are going,
well,
you know,
that has some upside but also has an awful lot of downside.
And we,
none of us are theocrats in the room.
I don't want a religiously oriented society where there's some king up top who's
telling everybody what to do apart from it.
But people are hungry for a set of eternal values.
Yeah.
And if they don't get those eternal values,
they will find something else to fill the hole.
And we'll be anger or will be drugs or will be hedonism or will be selfishness.
And it'd be ideology or ideology and all of these things.
And,
and I am an ideolog because my ideology is my values.
But it will be political ideology.
It will be political tribalism.
It'll be race based stuff.
It'll be ethnic and no centricity.
We all those things.
What we're doing by promoting a set of of values that that matter is we are
allowing people to,
to not only keep the cas at bay,
but but find a path amidst the chaos you,
Viktor Frankl says in man's search for meaning that in the middle of the
Holocaust,
what kept certain people alive and why did certain people die.
He said,
because if you were in the middle of the Holocaust living in the death camp,
it was the people who found some sense of purpose in the death camp who actually
got to live and how can you find purpose in the most purposeless place in the
history of humankind.
He said,
it didn't matter.
If human beings can find meaning living in a living in a concentration camp
where people are getting gassed to death every day,
then you certainly should be able to find meaning in the freest,
most rich,
most prosperous human society in the history of humanity.
Right?
Right,
right.
That Shapiro is how you ended.
I will add that the,
I like when people come up to me to,
of course,
Ben knows this,
there is a girl who works at the hardware store that's only a few blocks away
from here,
who always says to me,
Dave,
I'm a big fan of yours,
but I really liked that bench or bureau.
All right guys,
I will be with thanks to both of you.
[inaudible] you're the religious guy now,
right?
Um,
I will be at the Orpheum with Jordan on.
There can't be any tickets left,
right?
For the La show Saturday,
but you maybe can get them on stubhub or something like that and perhaps a
certain orthodox Jew will show up because it's after Shabbat.
You never know.
My wife thing is possible.
All right.
Thank you guys for watching.
Okay.